this is Jocko podcast number 354 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
in August of 2000 the militant Islamic
group Abu sayef in the in the southern
Philippines broadcast that had captured
a CIA agent
the truth was not as newsworthy or as
valuable to the rebels Abu sayyaf had
kidnapped Jeffrey Schilling a 24 year
old American who had traveled near their
base in Hollow Island
a California Native Shilling became a
hostage with a 10 million dollar price
tag on his head
at the time I was a supervisory special
agent
attached to the FBI's Elite crisis
negotiation unit the CNU the CNU is the
equivalent of the special forces of
negotiations
it's attached to the FBI's hostage
Rescue Team HRT both are National
counter-terrorist Response assets
they are the best of the best
I was a natural for the Shilling case I
had spent some time in the Philippines
and had an extensive background in
terrorism from my New York City days
assigned to the Joint terrorism task
force jttf
[Music]
a few days after Schilling became a
hostage my partner Chuck rajini and I
flew to Manila to run the negotiations
along with Jim Nixon the FBI's highest
official in Manila we conferred with the
top Philippine military brass
they agreed to let us guide the
negotiations
then we got down to business
one of us would take charge of the
negotiation strategy for the FBI and
consequently for the U.S government
that became my role
with the support of my colleagues my job
was to come up with a strategy get it
approved and implement it
our principal adversary was Abu sabaya
the rebel leader who personally
negotiated for Schilling's Ransom
sabaya was a veteran of the Rebel
movement with a violent past he was
straight out of the movies
a terrorist sociopath killer
he had a history of rape murder and
beheadings
he liked to record his bloody Deeds on
video and then send them to the
Philippine media
sabaya always wore sunglasses a bandana
a black T-shirt and camo pants
he thought it made him a more dashing
figure
if you look for any photos of Abu sayyaf
terrorists from this period you will
always see one in sunglasses that's
sabaya sabaya loved loved loved the
media
he had the Philippine reporters on speed
dial
they'd call him and ask him questions in
Tagalog his native tongue
he would answer in English because he
wanted the world to hear his voice on
CNN
they should make a movie about me he
would tell reporters
in my eyes sabaya was a cold-blooded
businessman with an ego as big as Texas
a real shark
sabaya knew he was in the Commodities
game
in Jeffrey Schilling he had an item of
value
how much could he get for it
he would find out and I intended it to
be a surprise he wouldn't like
as an FBI agent I wanted to free the
hostage and bring the criminal to
Justice
as a result of the Shilling case I would
become the FBI's lead International
kidnapping negotiator
and that right there
is a book as an excerpt from a book the
book is called Never split the
difference which is written by a man
named Chris Voss Chris Voss spent 24
years with the FBI where he spent time
as the lead crisis negotiator for the
New York City division of the FBI was
also the lead International kidnapping
negotiator
he was trained as a negotiator not only
by the FBI
but also by Harvard Law School and
Scotland Yard which is London's
Metropolitan Police
he worked the 1993 World Trade Center
bombing the TWA Flight 800 explosion
the cat the kidnapping of Jill Carroll
in Iraq in 2006
as well as countless other Dynamic
situations around the world
an incredible experiences
and it's a privilege tonight to have
Chris Voss with us here to discuss
what he's been through and what he's
learned Chris
thanks for joining us thanks man happy
to be here yeah it's uh by the way if I
ever have anybody else read my my book
I'll have you do the reading
let me know let me know I'm here to I'm
here to help out uh yeah fantastic book
yeah if people if you don't have this
yet you it's never split the difference
the subtitle is negotiating as if your
life depended on it
so fantastic book and we actually tried
to do this before covert or maybe right
before covid oh yeah but it didn't work
out and so glad you could finally get
out here and definitely looking forward
to this conversation
uh let's before we jump into the book
and all your lessons let's let's get a
little bit of background on you and how
you ended up here today so where'd you
grow up where'd you come from small town
in Iowa
uh son of a of Richard Joyce Voss my dad
was a blue collar entrepreneur owned his
own business my mom was
initially a stay-at-home mom that's what
they were back in those days and then
ultimately you know as their kids grew
up got involved in my father's aspects
of my father's business what was the
dad's business uh oil jobber originally
a middleman between uh show oil and the
end user which would usually be
um large Farms small companies and then
really the business when he bought it
was home heating oil
and I can remember my father going out
in the middle of the night in the middle
of winter because somebody's Furniture
shut down he had to fix it and they're
going to freeze and then uh after he got
into the business
according to him
um not not independently verified but it
certainly was a case
gas company came in and gave everybody
that had fuel oil furnaces free natural
gas service furnaces
took away all his customers by the time
that I graduated high school
we were one of the only houses that I
knew that was still burning fuel oil for
for heat
but he adapted you know you got to adapt
he expanded his business
bottom gas stations built some
convenience stores
saw himself as much in the energy
business as a fuel oil business and just
adapted and so what were you doing
growing up were you playing sports in
school do you like school what was the
deal there yeah well I played football
and basketball and and if I wanted to
run track I was allowed there were
certain things I wasn't allowed to do
like like one year one year I want to
play golf you know every every High
School's got a golf team
and the old man just wasn't having he
wasn't seeing that as as legitimate
um sporting activity that could divert
me away from working for him
so you know I had to my father believed
he put a roof over your head he fed you
he clothed you
you oh you're gonna go to work you got
paid but yeah you're going so what were
you working at the gas stations and
whatnot mostly
um the only time I ever worked at a gas
station it was for one that he didn't
own and it was a business associate
wanted to hire me on but most of the
time it was
um whatever needed to be done
maintenance driving trucks driving
tractors cutting grass painting
like I I did it painted a lot of stuff
in the summertime I to this day I hate
to pray you know he needed he needed a
house painted he had kids here here's
here's a bucket of paint here's a brush
here's a scaffold
well my favorite one was
he um wanted a new garage want to build
you know the house we bought had a
single car garage you barely
fit that one in he wants a new garage
I'm I'm probably about 11 or 12 at the
time my older sister's 13 or 14.
he hands his crowbars into go out in the
backyard tear down the garage
[Laughter]
and then and then so we're pretty much
tear the whole thing down
and we got the foundation left
and you you got to knock the foundation
out and uh the old man thinks all right
well I'll go run a jackhammer I'll put
my kid my 12 year old on a jackhammer
on the foundation and I I don't know I'm
like all right Dad you know
and the foundation was so big I couldn't
break it up with a jackhammer so you
have financed a higher contractor this
guy comes in with a backhoe and I'm
thinking
an adult man needs a backhoe to take
this out and I'm out here with a hammer
and nails and a jackhammer and I'm 12.
yeah
so uh just you you're doing good in
school Fair
um I was capable of better grades than I
felt like getting
um
uh mostly a b student did you have
interest in going to college what was
your what was your future looking like
when you were like 16 years old College
college was always part of the game plan
like my for whatever reason it was just
always accepted that all this uh older
sister and two younger
accepted we were going to go to college
your man was going to spring for four
years of tuition
if you graduated or not that was on you
finite amount of money you know got got
certain amount of money put in my
checking account start of every session
if I spent it or not it was up to me
um
and I just you know it was just and then
whatever happened after that was pretty
much up to us
and so where'd you end up going to
College Iowa State University my older
sister went there one reason to go
um you know I really idolized her
growing up and she was there sort of
plowing the ground it was far enough
away from home that I wouldn't have to
work in evenings or be expected to work
on the weekends
you know because if we get out of that
work radius
three and a half hour drive
on a whim he can't call me back at four
because he needs something down to five
but it was also close enough to get back
on a weekend if I needed to for whatever
reason and no wrestling for you growing
up in Iowa ah good observation nah I
wasn't I wasn't into wrestling A Home of
a lot of great wrestling yeah it gave a
bunch a bunch of folks Iowa State
Cyclones were running Championship after
championship in those days
um the the 190 pound wrestler Frank
Santana I remember him
but no I was a basketball player I
wasn't a Grappler those Seasons Clash
now at what point did you start looking
at law enforcement
actually when I was 16 a buddy of mine
and I went and saw of a uh based on a
true story true life movie The Super
cops
two cops in New York
somebody recently actually found me a
DVD of it sent it to me
um
these guys worked in Bed Stuy back when
bed style was a really bad area
white dudes
very black Area Community loved them
loved them these guys
locked up bad people and the good people
in the community appreciated the heck
out of it and these guys were extremely
creative I didn't realize that at the
time the other thing that really
attracted me to a complete Mavericks
like didn't pay attention to what the
bosses told them
and put a lot of bad people in jail were
very very creative about it and uh the
uh the community actually nicknamed them
bad rap Batman and Robin
that's that's awesome except for the
dude that got stuck being Robin yeah who
wants to be Robin right
but then then uh me and my buddy saw
this when I remember we were 16 and we
both got struck at that moment in time
we want to be in law enforcement
and I stayed in in law enforcement is
occasionally a harsh reality
and my buddy went to Phoenix got on the
police department there and
the harshness of it he just wasn't built
for it and he didn't last
this was the guy that saw the movie with
you yeah did you what'd you study in
college
um ultimately was a business degree
uh they didn't call it that back then
they would call it industrial
Administration but it was a business
degree
and uh I started out originally
you know I I got in the engineering
school I switched out as soon as I was
there switched to Sociology
but then I realized that a lot of
sociologists out of work what if I
changed my mind about being a cop
so I decided to go to business just to
have the flexibility of going whatever
Direction I wanted to go so do you
graduate in four years four you got out
of four years and then was it straight
to the police academy somewhere
yeah I went well and initially I wanted
to go to Kansas City Missouri
I uh I'd never been there
but everybody in that part of the world
the three cities for choices were
principally Kansas City St Louis and
Chicago
originally I had my heart set on San
Francisco
and because we had visited there my
family went there when I was about 18. I
thought this is a cool town it's really
interesting place
and then a thing called proposition came
through in Calif Proposition 13 came
through in California
where they cut back on all the property
taxes I figured they were going to
impact the municipal budgets negatively
probably a guy from out of state is
going to have trouble getting hired
so then I just decided stay local and
everybody that I knew
that have been to Kansas City said this
is a great town
and so I just went and applied
completely out of the blue
they were they told me they were not
hiring when I graduated I remember when
I graduated I was really depressed
because I didn't know where I was going
to go didn't want to go back home and
work for my father
but I had nowhere else to go
and Kansas City although they knew
internally that June 1 it was going to
be a new fiscal year and a new world
they're telling me at the time now we
got no idea when we're gonna hire just
no idea this is May so they had to have
known they were going to iron you
and a new fiscal year came in they
started a new class I was in a class
how'd they notify you
ah interesting I may have gotten a
letter I don't I don't even actually
remember
so you didn't think you had a job then
all of a sudden you got a job suddenly I
had a job and then in the meantime like
I'm I'm back working from my dad driving
a truck your dad's like got your life
plotted out for you you're fine you're a
kid you know
and and also like just to get into law
enforcement I remember
I applied for Sheriff's Department got
turned down
and then I had done an internship with
the Iowa Department of Public Safety
and
I can't remember exactly why I don't
think I wanted to be in Iowa I didn't
want to be an Iowa highway patrol if I
was going to be uniform I want to be in
a city
and I remember being told from the
police people in the Department of
Public Safety like you could walk right
into the highway patrol because I'd had
an internship with him the year before
so they knew me they knew I was an
honest guy and that
however Innovative I was I also really
wasn't a rule breaker
you know I was going to follow the rules
um but I I didn't want to I didn't want
to be a highway patrolman so I held up
for Kansas City want to be in a city and
got in there so you so you end up in
Kansas City how's that like uh going to
the police academy how is that a boot
camp scenario is it a gentleman's course
is it you go home in the afternoon are
you staying in Barracks how does that
all work yeah they had just moved the
police academy into a local community
college I think for budgetary reasons
they had their own Academy in its own
Standalone campus where they controlled
all aspects of it and for whatever
reason which I'm sure is budgetary they
abandoned that so we're in a community
college
um combination of classroom not quite
boot camp plus you're going home to your
own apartment every night
they uh six months
uh PT every day
and something that I think law
enforcement has really lost sight of
like the neck restraint the Carotid
restraint
we worked on that every single day for
six months
like nobody that I ever worked with ever
heard anybody by misapplication of the
neck restraint and they knew they they
knew that it was potentially lethal and
if there was one thing they were going
to do we're going to be in condition
relatively speaking not seal condition
but in condition
but we weren't going to hurt anybody
even putting a neck restraint on them we
worked on that every day for six months
yeah it's a just a horrible thing to see
happening right now with law enforcement
I mean I talked to a lot of police
officers around the country and in most
places right now
you cannot use a neck restraint it's
considered lethal force and you you you
cannot use it right
um and as anybody that knows anything it
is absolutely the best way to get
someone under control that's out of
control without hurting them and if
somebody had to restrain my wife or my
daughter I would beg that they please
use a neck restraint because
they'll be fine uh so it's it's great to
hear that at some point in time you were
training that way and you did it every
day so you learn how effective it is you
also learn what to be careful of right
so yeah that that makes sense like one
one cop and I um we had to Corral this
gorilla uh and just you know Caucasian
just for the record
but this monstrous dude at the mental
hospital
which means like normally somebody's is
nuts and big as that once you Corral
them you take them to the mental
hospital so when a mental hospital calls
you to get somebody out of there you
know you got a problem
if we would have been able to choke that
guy out with the proper carotid
restraint I don't know how we'd have got
him out of there without shooting him
like and we got him out out of there
completely unarmed yeah yeah
that's a that's a horrible escalation to
go from oh this guy's a problem and now
I have to shoot him because I don't know
what else to do or I'm not allowed to do
anything else that escalation from this
guy's going to be perfect literally
perfectly fine to now he's dead because
I didn't have I wasn't authorized to use
the tools that I should be authorized to
use and should be trained properly uh
that's awful
so it's a six-month School six month
Academy in a community college
um trying to maintain quasi military
discipline which emotional enforcement
kind of quasi
and it was it was yeah it was a good
classroom working out occasionally a
couple times a week going to the range
and like when you're when you're saying
classrooms is like four or five hours of
Class A Day you learn about the laws you
learn about what you can and cannot do
yeah that kind of stuff
combination
constitutional law
some understanding probable cause
uh administrative
rules and regulations that we're going
to have to know just to get by on the
street you know I can remember the first
time
a standard Report Form was a form 189.
and so they they say we're going to
learn how to fill out a form 189. I
remember thinking like I got to remember
189 forms
I was relieved that I didn't have to
memorize 189 forms
so did you feel pretty good do you feel
pretty prepared when you ended up you
know you get your badge you go to the
street how did you feel like you're
pretty prepared for it well I felt like
I was I certainly did
uh there were a couple things
uh that took getting used to like
initially I was so nervous my breaking
officer was scared to let me drive
and then uh you know the complexity of
being on patrol listening to the radio
and actually being on patrol
most initially you can't do both so if
you're really paying attention to your
environment if you're looking around if
you're listening you're not going to
hear the radio yeah and finally
somebody's going to come by and say
we've been calling you for 20 minutes
but then and then you just keep keep
doing it every day every day every day
and then suddenly something clicks and
you're pulling in all the information
and you're dialing
so you have a break-in officer is that
the term you used yeah yeah for two
months
um
they you know they want to see whether
or not they're going to Turn You Loose
Kansas City at the time ran one-man car
Patrols
so when you got cut loose off break-in
you were riding around by yourself
which is for a variety of reasons
actually I'm here now really a good
Patrol strategy why is that what I just
heard recently
uh unsourced
that
a male police officer is less likely to
overreact to a challenge if he's by
himself
and if there's two males there
two male police officers at the initial
challenge
you're a little more likely to overreact
because there's another male there that
you're afraid of losing face in front of
I don't know how true that is
it makes sense to me for a variety of
reasons there's some more complexity to
it
you know I held off before
talking to you about the different
people you've had on
um huberman
um
yeah and I saw yeah you had him in I
think he's brilliant he's brilliant dude
I happened I I had the Good Fortune to
have lunch with him one day
and um
so I'm very much into the Neuroscience
aspects these days and on one of his
podcasts he was talking about
again separating out the problems with
law enforcement
and it happened to be a podcast on love
and relationships I think
and as I recall he's talking about uh
the basic for neurochemical hormones
that drive us and as I recall is
primarily
testosterone serotonin oxytocin
serotonin
and he said if you're essentially a
testosterone type
you're more likely to see things as a
challenge
so let's get out of race and get into
type
you got a testosterone driven cop
stopping a testosterone-driven male
and they're both going to see almost
everything that happens as a challenge
you can expect that to turn into a
downward spiral absent better training
it's got nothing to do with race the
dynamic that I thought you were going to
say is
if I'm pulling you over and I'm by
myself
well I'm by myself so I better
de-escalate right I better be thinking
another Point yeah whereas if I'm with
Echo and he's my partner and you start
getting mouthy old you know we're gonna
kick your ass I feel more confident more
just like in a bar right the guy that's
in the bar that's by himself oh he's not
causing any problems it's the guy that's
with three of his friends and all of a
sudden he's getting mouthy right no
that's yeah exactly right and and most
police departments are running
um two-man patrols two-person patrols
yeah it's weird for me because in my
background in the SEAL Teams you
if any possible way you have a buddy
with you as a matter of fact if you
don't have a buddy with you you're kind
of getting in trouble so you're always
because you know you can't watch your
back you know you you just can't right
so you always have someone with you so
I've always thought to myself man if I
was a police officer I'd really like to
have a partner
um well you're trained too I mean you're
trained to not let your your negative
emotions gonna get out of control
yeah uh I would definitely you know any
the same thing in the SEAL Teams I mean
you got to learn to de-escalate things
and and just being in a leadership
position you got to learn to de-escalate
things because someone's comes in and
they're mad about something and if
you're in a leadership position and all
you do is go back at them you see see
they you know Boston's plan sucks and
you think oh you're challenging me
instead of saying oh well what sucks
about the plan do you want to make some
adjustments to it like that's what you
do that's how you de-escalate it you
don't say well you don't understand the
whole problem I dare you so right yeah
uh yeah that takes some training so that
takes some uh some mental gymnastics to
get to a point where you can do that
um
so now you're out there in Kansas City a
couple months was there any moment where
you felt like like oh I messed up or or
did you ever feel like okay now I'm a
cop
you know what I'm saying no I loved it
my first year there I loved it I
absolutely loved it I was in a
commercial area
you know it's a fair amount of street
life
um
a little more fast-paced
and that suited me I'm not a real
meticulous
super organized super patient
by nature and nurture I'm not sure which
but neither one
so my first year I had I had a ball I
mean I had a ball I mean I was putting
bad guys in jail
you know I really loved it
I can remember
um
my parents came to visit me one time and
we we met at the uh they came by the
precinct
towards the end of my shift and I was
told they were there so we drove up and
my mom said when she saw me get out of
the car
she said the way you moved when you got
out of the car I saw a cop get out of
that car
so then after I was there for a year
they switched me to a residential area
which is a different kind of work
you know you're not you're not making
locking up multiple guys in a night
um you're looking for residential
burglars
it's much more painstaking meticulous
patient work
and so I went from an area that I just
loved to an area that I just wasn't I
wasn't built for and I and I started
getting bored while I was there
is that when you started looking for
something else to do well you know I
don't know that I looked so much for
something else to do
um I was gonna I was planning on I
wanted to become a member of the SWAT
team
and it took three years
to get on the SWAT team so I'm I'm there
you know two-ish years
and the guys I knew most of the guys
that were on a SWAT team and they said
well you know put in for the selection
process you know just go through it if
you put in then the Commander's cams and
sergeants are going to get to know that
you're interested they're going to keep
an eye on you then next time around
you got a better shot
so all right cool so I I put in for the
selection process ended up number one on
the list
number one no shocked everybody
so the the captains went to the
lieutenant colonel and said let's wave
the three-year rule on number one guy
here
isn't going to have three years for 10
more months
and Lieutenant Colonel said I don't care
[Music]
rules are rules we're not we're not
waving them so
I'm going to precinct on board by
they're they're taking everybody on the
list under me one at a time
and there was even the discussion of the
possibility that if they took everybody
they still wouldn't take me they'd be a
whole new selection process
so I'm a little annoyed by this and that
my father
says um what you think about Federal
oh my God I'm happy in Kansas City
so he introduces me this guy with the
Secret Service
and I talked to this guy and uh he says
you know
I've traveled all over the world with
the Secret Service
and I remember thinking
somebody paid you and paid for your
flights and paid for your hotel to go
all over the world like I'm from Iowa
like I you know I'd seen Canada from a
distance that was the extent of my
international travel
so I'm like that sounds cool and so I
didn't know one Federal agency from
another
no idea
Secret Service I will go down there
we're not hiring not hiring so I see an
article in a newspaper uh FBI's first
billion dollar budget
I knew enough about budgets that I
thought it's got to be salaries they're
going to be hiring
I went down I put in it was the first of
a three-year hiring push
and uh and I got in
and just like that so how long is it
between when you get accepted and when
you're going to the FBI Academy
yeah well
October 31st
I'd had three years on the police
department
and I would have gone to the SWAT team
the bureau hired me on October 15th
and I remember you know I'm a dumb 20
something year old
I put in for the bureau
and I remember literally telling people
you know whoever whoever offers me a
position first
SWAT team comes I'm going with a SWAT
team the bureau comes I'm going with the
bureau
and then they kept uh the police
department had had a the chief at the
time hated the FBI with a passion hated
the FBI
so they had a rule
that if you left the police department
the only job you couldn't come back from
was it you became an FBI agent a Hugo
took a job as a dog catcher they'd take
it back you go take a job you know think
of something a hairdresser you know I
don't know what
but the only job and in my exit
interview they they literally told me
they said you understand you can never
come back if you joined a bureau like
well it's not my intention to come back
but so consequently they had to I had to
keep my application a secret until it
was in a final stages they couldn't go
interview any of my commanders until
just they were sure that they were going
to hire me at the last minute
and you know that led I was still a
mouthy 20 something so that led to a
couple of problems as I was leaving the
police department what's the beef
where's the beef did this guy have a
specific beef with the FBI
was it like a case where the feds came
in like straight out of a movie he had
[Music]
um
jurisdiction right scene
talking on the street with ladies of the
evening
and that uh a couple of Bureau guys
spotted him on the street
with these ladies of the evening
on the way to a meeting
and it made it back to the city council
because the agents were wondering
whether or not they could trust the guy
and they said you know I don't work with
this guy and then he went on to like the
FBI this is how bad it got under this
guy
I don't know if you're familiar with the
FBI National Academy yeah but if you get
if you get sent to the National Academy
Bureau pays all your expenses space pays
for your flights like doesn't cost an
agency a dime to send somebody to the
National Academy and it's a stepping
stone in a lot of police departments to
be becoming chief for the next promotion
it's a big deal yeah
and I spoke at the last FBI National
Academy meeting yeah it was awesome so I
get there in the FBI Academy you know uh
October 15th
and they start talking about how they
pay all expenses for cops and I'm
thinking
nobody from Kansas City has come here in
10 years it it can't be that it's free
like now it's free that's that's how
much this guy hated the FBI well
so you get picked up for the FBI uh you
show up to the academy how's the academy
yeah it was good
um
you know running shooting mostly
academic the
um uh the physical aspects of it were
not super challenging
you could if uh it would help you at the
time you could be in no condition at all
and they'd whip you into shape they
ended up having
um
problems with that later on and so now
you can't get in unless you're in at
least a minimal physical condition
but you you could come in and be fat
completely out of shape if you put in
the effort you'd meet the minimums
and they weren't huge like FBI agents
are not wrestling people to the ground
on a regular basis so they want you to
be physically capable
but you know it was more rigorous than a
police department because you you might
get into a wrestling match with somebody
every day
and the bureau's uh tactics is to outman
outgun the bad guys so that physical
confrontations are unnecessary
so they want you to be able to handle
yourself but it's not that big of a deal
they really want you they want you to do
the classroom work they want you to be
able to shoot well my shooting improved
significantly from when I was there and
it was it was it was good solid 16 weeks
it was transformative how are you
looking at because you're a you're a cop
coming off the Mean Streets and how are
you looking at the college kids is there
is there like uh fun with that with that
interaction yeah it was I was a lot more
um
harsh so to speak more aggressive more
blunt
than the vast majority of them were
um I I was
and they come from all walks of life and
they're going to turn them into agents
but I was you know I was I was a street
cop what percentage of people are
previous cops rolling in there pretty
small
pretty small they're at the time
they hired in five categories
I was cops are in the modified category
which is all others like you're not a
lawyer you're not an accountant you're
not a scientist you're not a female
you're not a minority
uh you're not any others you're not a
language you know you don't you're not
already fluent so everybody else goes
into a large categories modified and
you know it's a more competitive
theoretically it's just more more people
there
um and I was modified so not that many
cops was there any uh did you have any
challenges when you were there is
anything hard for you
no I don't think so no nothing nothing
there then I mean I could I was already
in decent condition took care of myself
pretty well
I could study when I felt like it and I
already knew how to shoot do people get
kicked out of the academy like what
percentage of people make it through I
mean they got a good screening progress
program so I'm sure it's not that many
no yeah there's well it's even it's even
better now
um
uh and no not that many did not not that
many did like if if you got if you got
caught lying about anything you should
you should be shutting the door
um any any cheating should be shown the
door
if you that was they had a problem with
physical conditioning
because they tried they wouldn't Force
official physical conditioning rules
in the academy but then not once you
join we're actually in a field office as
an agent
and somebody brought up well if if
legally your full FBI agents from the
moment you walk in the door
you shouldn't get fired and from the
academy on something you won't get fired
from if you're in a field office
and
you should be you shouldn't be fat and
out of shape in a field office they just
weren't firing people for them so they
then they then they just raise the
physical minimums to get in the door
are you when you're there
so is is everyone getting trained just
to be an agent yeah and is there do you
go to Specialty training after that so
if I'm an accountant and they think I'm
gonna be looking at tax fraud do I go
there I become an agent and then I go to
an advanced school to be uh you know a
tax fraud guy pretty much exactly yeah
the theory then and I think it still
holds pretty true now like being an FBI
agent first specialize I have towards we
got to make sure that you understand how
to how to be a generalist before you you
know you
follow your bliss for like lack of a
better term like somebody's breaking a
law
on every cool thing you could think of
like if you were into collecting postage
stamps
somebody's engaged in an active criminal
Enterprise making money from accountable
I get a matter
so the cool thing about the FBI is that
ultimately
if you take your time
you can have the best time
investigating crimes around stuff you're
really interested in
but uh if I speak
Spanish or I speak Russian are they
going to throw me into an assignment
where this is my main gig as soon as I
get done Spanish guys for a while
everybody had that if you got hired in
the Spanish program
everybody was going to have to do a
stint in Puerto Rico
those were the only ones at the time
Puerto Rico's
bureau's got his hands full in Puerto
Rico Puerto Rico is
doesn't know if wants to be state or a
commonwealth
you know infrastructure problems uh on
us on the one hand still uh you know
back in my time in a bureau still a
couple of active groups that engaging in
violence for Independence
um
so this just this crazy combination of
very difficult things to working in
Puerto Rico so if you're a Spanish
speaker you're going to do time in
Puerto Rico that was the only language
so as a normal agent would for you for
instance do you get any any say in where
you're going and what you're getting
assigned to no they're just going to
give you what they're going to get not
then but then the bureaus
uh policy which made was made complete
sense
like starting your life over as an FBI
agent it's a big jump
and the easiest way effectively is to go
into witness security program
complete new identity no ties to your
old identity at all
because it's the easiest way to become
an FBI agent like nobody nobody you're
not around people with the high school
with you're not around your neighbors
you're not not even around family oh so
you're saying not literally
like it's witness protection but they
take you and they're not going to send
you back to where you're from right
they're going to send you to some other
city so you don't have to run into the
people you used to know you're going to
be right it's a new life that was back
then now the problem with that it was
very expensive
to I'm I'm in Kansas City they send me
to Pittsburgh for two years
they get me ready to go into one of
major offices is this what they actually
did with you yeah so this is your first
assignment is Pittsburgh two years in
Pittsburgh do you get some kind of a
special assignment like you're gonna be
working gang you're gonna be working
drug you're gonna be or are you just
working
um you most offices start you out
working working applicants
because you got to get used to Landing
credentials on somebody
in a low stress environment so if you're
doing a background investigation you're
walking into a bank because somebody
used to work in a bank wants to become
an agent or something else where the
background's required geez that's not
the rush you were looking for was it
it's a little slow to start I would but
you know the first couple times you know
these crazy things where you hold your
your creds up in front of somebody yeah
you're used to that
and but or if you're going into a bank
to lock somebody up that's a whole
different so they they warm you up in
applicants and then depend upon where
you are where you're gonna get assigned
to I initially get to sign
to foreign counterintelligence FCI
working spies which is not for me
again that's slow meticulous work
and so I within the rules now I'm
scheming on how to get out of there
uh you you get there you get assigned
this foreign counterintelligence you
already know this is really not your gig
well so what's your scam what do you run
how do you try and maneuver well as it
turns out
the guys ahead of the office his kid is
getting ready to go to college in Iowa
State
so I'm not that far from out of Iowa
State I'm like look you know I'll
connect you with some friends
you know what we'll help make sure your
Landing is is a soft landing and you
know I helped look out for his kid
building some relationships relationship
building
and so then he initially I want to go to
The Drug Squad drug and organized crime
the different choices they get a bank
robbery Squad great Squad I got no shot
at the bank for every Squad drug and
organized crime or white collar so let
me do the drugs in organized crime
this guy I'm told
he's going to send me a drug and
organized crime
and then when the transfer comes through
I'm on surveillance
which ended up being a great thing it
was better than FCI
uh but then you you know that's that
assignment played into where I ended up
in New York and surveillance is you
could experiment with stuff and um
and all the field of visions
surveillance is a light undercover that
you got you got a name different last
name you got the ID you got credit cards
any event that you gotta somebody you're
following whether it's a drug dealer or
a spy
gets on a plane you got to go with them
you got to be able to pay for it you
know you you got to be able to go
so I get a chance to do some
undercover work there also because then
they're they're borrowing the guys in
their surveillance teams you've already
got an undercover backstop you go out
and buy do drug buys
and that's when I found out to being
undercover is the lie for a living
and it didn't fit me didn't suit me some
some people it's fine it works for you
but lying for a living didn't work for
me and undercover sounds sexy everybody
wants to do undercover I mean that
sounds sexy I want to get out they want
to buy drugs you know I want to go in
and organize cry I want to do all this
stuff
and until you try it something that
sounds sexy you don't really know if
it's for you so I got a chance to try it
a couple of a few times in in Pittsburgh
and I just realized it just wasn't for
me
I had uh two friends
one of them went to the FBI the other
was trying to go from the SEAL Teams to
the FBI the other one was going to
another agency inside the government and
they both went to the screening
and the guy that was going to the FBI
comes back he's got took the freaking
lie detector test that thing was crazy
you know as soon as they out they said
uh pick a number between one and five
and tell us you know don't tell us the
number when we ask you if it's a number
and he goes okay and so he's you know
thinking of three and they go is it one
and he goes no and the the thing's all
flat he goes is it two and he goes no as
soon as he says that he goes if the
thing starts going wild is it three he
said it's off he goes they knew exactly
because I told him that
and and he was one of those guys like he
just wasn't comfortable lying and it
just it just called him out now my other
friend who went to another agency he
comes back from his interview
he goes yeah I took that lie detector
test and I go how was that he goes I
flatlined it
and the the he said he just yeah just
that thing couldn't he also did I just I
just blew through it and here's the
thing I actually don't know if he's like
because he lied a lot this guy you know
he was one of those guys that told like
small small lies all the time you know
he's talking to a girl he's telling a
little crazy story he's talking to some
other dude he's telling us something
even when he's talking to you you know
you know those kind of friends that you
have where they you know they're kind of
lying about stuff like you know and
you're good with it it's just White Lies
but it's all the time he was one of
those guys and so I kind of believed him
when he told me he flatlined the thing
he probably yeah but he may have been
even lying about that I'm not sure uh
but that idea you know for me I'm like
you like I don't want to be I don't like
to have like I don't like to have to
cover like lie about stuff and make
stuff up and it just doesn't sit well
with me I wouldn't be a good undercover
guy uh so how long did you have to do
that for
I was I worked surveillance for about a
year and a half a year now a lot of
times you're just straight up sitting in
like the plumbing van on the corner with
a camera taking pictures that's what
you're doing yeah or even if even if
you're in a Chase vehicle where you're
following them like they're they're
moving for of an eight ten hour shift
they're moving for an hour max so you're
sitting around no matter what
so this is still not what you came in to
do no you know I wasn't it wasn't you
know I'm and I'm I'm buying my time in
Pittsburgh at the time because I knew
that you know I'm gonna be out of there
soon
what is it a two-year assignments that
you guys get roughly at the time it was
roughly two years for the movie onto one
of the top offices they called it the
top 12 the time
but everybody was going to New York at
the time
um every FBI agent everyone in the
country got paid the same amount of
money if you were if you're an agent in
Kansas City if you're an agent my
hometown Mount Pleasant Iowa
you get paid the exact same amount of
money somebody in New York got paid so
consequently there were people in New
York were quitting right and left they
were having trouble Staffing the office
and they said look you're going to New
York I mean the orders aren't here yet
but nine out of 10 of you coming out of
this class
you guys are all going to end up in New
York so you're going
don't be shocked when your orders for
New York come through so I'm in
Pittsburgh I'm waiting for the orders to
New York to come through and so what
year is this that you finally get orders
to New York 1985.
1985. the day my son Brandon was born
was the exact same day I got my orders
to New York were printed
you roll up to New York and what what do
you get assigned when you get up there I
catch a break
um
since I got surveillance time and since
I've been a cop
The Joint terrorist task force the
surveillance team dedicated to them
uh needed needed bodies and I because of
my surveillance time I got put right on
so that was that was a huge break for a
whole bunch of reasons
um
it was I saved a lot of money
didn't have to pay for suits and dry
cleaning
that's uh you know the cost of living is
now increased so my living standard is
taking a step back
and then the second thing was at the
time the surveillance teams were the
only guys that took cars home
surveillance and SWAT took cars home
and so this takes care of all my
commuting expenses which is another
significant chunk of cash
so and then I'm with New York City cops
as partners a joint terrorist task force
surveillance team but the coolest thing
of it was we were the only surveillance
team in New York
that actually got out on the street
with people went into the subway
you had to be prepared
to end up anywhere in New York City at
one o'clock in the morning toughest
neighborhood by yourself
no comms with anybody like totally on
your own
and you develop you know it's a New York
very dangerous time 19 mid to late 80s
very dangerous yeah so if you're if
you're into this job like this is great
this is Disney World every day like how
do you end up in the South Bronx and the
bad guys leave you alone
I remember the first time I'm going
through bedside about one o'clock in the
morning
and we you know we could use pay phones
you know you had special number you
could use a pay phone that cost you
I called some friends of mine in Iowa to
say guess where I am at right now I am
in Bed Stuy in a drug neighborhood
hanging out
now you're you said you were the
counter-terrorist team is that right
yeah well joint terrorist task force
task force yeah you know I think I I
know there's some terms of art for
anti-terrorist versus counter-terrorists
I think we're counter terrorists and so
who are you tracking how are you ending
up in you know some drug infested part
of the city who you tracking it was it
was a very cool transition time
the terrorist task force started out
mostly all domestic terrorism
and had
every ethnic group had a terrorist group
Puerto Ricans had the fla and the
marchitaros
Jewish jdl bombers
um
black panthers had turned into the Black
Liberation Army
and the most dangerous one of all
the May 19th communist organization
which was mostly
white female lesbians
and they were the smartest
the most organized the most effective of
all the groups like they we had more
respect
for their organization and and the way
they and at one point in time
domestically all the groups got together
because it's like a professional
association where you have confidence
they know they hang out together they
know each other and they did a couple
joint operations and on May 19th were so
disappointed in the organization of the
other groups and they finally said you
guys go on your own
so the first first generation of
terrorist task force put them all in
jail I mean knocked them out they they
you know they want Awards right and left
books were written about all the cases
they made
so I get there and I join that just as
that's going away
and simultaneously just as
the Islamic radicals are starting to
come to town
like I get there just a couple of years
before the first World Trade Center
bombing and and we're seeing a shift
but the bizarre part of it was
no one believed this
no one believed no one no one no one FBI
headquarters New York City Police
Department
they were actually in the process of
disbanding the terrorist task force
when the first world Trader Center
bombing occurred in 93
some of my supervisors
uh a a deputy chief famously said to one
of my supervisors you're telling me
about pink elephants walking down
Broadway
because they felt there was no terrorism
in the United States because none of the
incidents were were occurring on
American soil
and we had all been reassigned to gang
crimes gang crimes was was a really big
thing at the time
and they took us they disbanded the
terrorist task force and who reassigned
us all the gangs so you're there
they disband this terrorist task force
after they kind of broke a bunch of
these domestic terrorist groups of
they say ah there's no more threat were
you guys already saying hey no there's
an Islamic extremist threat or were you
not quite there yet we weren't we
weren't quite there yet we since
something was going on and so we took
all our terrorist cases and made them
gang cases because they qualified as
gang cases okay so you guys are now part
of this gang task force we're working
gang crimes
you know the the different groups
whether whether wherever they had
originated from at the different time at
the time there were a couple of uh bank
robbery Crews
that were they realized if we call where
we hang out a mosque
then we just pulled another layer of the
First Amendment over us and it's that
much harder to get to get at us so they
said you know the criminals and they're
and every religion has legitimate
um practitioners
so it's not the legitimate
practitioner's fault
that the criminals
change the name of the building and hang
out in to a mosque
and that that's what a bunch of them did
and we went from literally the First
World Trade Center bombing
a couple of guys that were investigating
some bank robberies
we're trying to get a wire in a building
that the bank robbers said was a mosque
and the prosecutors wouldn't touch it
they're like we are not we don't care
what you find
we are not putting a wire in a church
and then the Trade Center happened and I
turned right back around
and with all the probable cause we'd
previously established we got the wires
that we needed right after the first
Trade Center bombing what was your well
so were you in that gang task force
doing surveillance when the first uh
World Trade Center attack happened I had
been I had shifted from surveillance to
what we call going inside being part of
the investigative Squad so I was no
longer doing like cover
and I had been doing
um investigations
uh overtly
for probably about two years when the
First Trade Center bombing happened how
how uh how surprised were we on that
first World Trade Center bombing like no
yeah completely
um there were some cases that we had had
working
we just we didn't imagine we we didn't
have our arms around the guys that did
the bombing
we actually had we were looking real
hard at a particular group that engaged
in a test blast
of the Trade Center explosive
they were tricked into
the test blast they didn't even know
what was going on the opsec of the guys
that hit the First Trade Center was
really really good
and uh Ramsey Youssef Master minor First
Trade Center bombing who is in fact
College Sheikh mohammed's nephew 911
Mastermind
his nephew Ramsey Youssef did the first
he came to town
he brought the plants with him
he found a bunch of disorganized guys
you know nobody nobody really
appreciated what he was how organized he
was
he pulled the whole thing together and
left New York shortly before the bomb
went off
and we got lucky on that bombing I mean
the amount of damage yeah I could have
done ridiculous ridiculously lucky
and their intention was first time was
to take the tower down yeah they placed
a bomb in a position to try to drop one
Tower into the next
and when Ramsay came back when we
brought him back collectively I'm told
that they flew by the Trade Center and
he told the guys that I'm playing next
time we're taking it down
okay
how did this impact your job so once
this happens is it like full Focus now
you realize you gotta you gotta pay the
the FBI needs to pay attention to the
Islamic extremists yeah we well we got
we got on them in a hurry
um we we've been working different
aspects of the group for about five
years
and everything they did there was
tremendous restrictions on terrorist
investigations because they saw it as a
political investigation
so the oversight like we had to
re-justify the cases every six months
and if you had if they hadn't committed
a crime or we hadn't turned up a crime
in that six-month time frame
the investigation just got shut down you
couldn't pursue it
so but consequently we had little bits
and pieces all along that when they hit
the Trade Center we could go back to the
previous cases well here's a piece here
here's a piece here here's a piece here
and we now now saw how the group had uh
coalesced in in the United States
by not breaking a law in their own way
for example one guy
um one of the Ring leaders got stopped
at a car pulled over in a car stopped
trunk load of weapons
one of the one of the passengers in a
car had a federal firearms license
it had dealer tags on a car wasn't to
write the reason it got stopped was
because the tags didn't match the car
they had legitimate reason for having a
dealer tags do you have a license plate
you put on any car you want driving
around you're golden so legitimate car
stopped within the laws of the United
States no reason to take anybody to jail
when we start backtracking we see same
guys in a car with a bunch of weapons on
the way to a firing range
so we when when we could bring all the
pieces together it all came together
pretty fast
at what point did you get interested or
start to get involved in negotiation
yeah I had uh I had I would say it would
be fair to say utterly no interest
and be in a hostage negotiator when I
first joined a bureau
I was on a SWAT team in Pittsburgh
I got to New York I tried out for HRT
that I was ridiculously underprepared
when I tried our prayer chart they I was
just like sad
but um knew that I could do it if I
worked at it you know you can't train a
couple weekends you gotta you gotta
train your your tail off for a year it's
got to become a lifestyle yeah I don't
have to tell you that I mean that's what
it is it's a lifestyle
so I tried out for HRT and um
failed miserably
and then started working out again and
read you my knee had my knee put back
together for the second time
and then I thought all right so
and as probably as you well know there's
a shelf life that's special
operation Special Forces then you were
expired you're going to expire at some
point in time you know something's going
to break too many times and you're not
going to be able to do it anymore
uh so then I thought all right so we got
negotiators I've seen these guys out
there they're there all the time crisis
response
uh be a negotiator because crisis
requires a decision
somebody's got to decide what to do and
decide now
and I wanted to stay in that game and do
it so I thought I'd I thought I would
angle myself towards a negotiation team
and had to jump through some hoops but
eventually made it so this is what year
is this that you that you make it to
negotiation team I get trained in 90
two
92. you've seen last century
1992 before cell phones and and so this
is inside the FBI there's a Detachment
of negotiators is that the way it's set
up you can do it as an additional duty
like when you're a street agent
there's something in you there's four
basic additional assignments something
in you is going to resonate with one of
those four you can be an undercover you
could be a negotiator
you could be in Swat
you could be in a bomb Tech
each one of those a little bit different
breed of cat
and something in you is really going to
line up with one of those things
and so if that was out for you yeah
swats out because the knee
and I was interested in negotiation and
what you do if you if if they take you
on the team then they send you to
Quantico for two weeks to get that
training there's three schools in the
world that every hostage negotiator
wants to go to
you want to go to the bureau school you
want to go to London Matt Scotland Yard
and then you're either going to want to
go down to Australia you're going to
want to go to Canada because both of
those run great Great Courses
so the bureau the bureau's course
as opposed to the Scotland yards course
the bureau's course will turn you into
the best hostage negotiator you could be
Scotland Yard turn you into a great team
player which I had no idea was there was
a difference then
but there's a huge difference
so I went to the bureau school and
learned how to negotiate so you're this
is when you're still part of the gang
task force right you get this collateral
Duty right as a negotiator so if
something was to pop up where a
negotiator was needed they'd call you
you'd get brought in right whereas some
other guy that became a bomb Tech all of
a sudden there's a bomb they find a pipe
bomb somewhere they needed someone to go
work on that they call one of the bomb
Tech guys that's been to that school
exactly and so forth okay so you've been
trained now once you've been trained in
that did you start to realize this is
kind of something that you're good at
did you realize it was something you
were more interested in you thought you
would be well I had volunteered on a
suicide hotline before I went to the
negotiations rating wait you volunteered
on a what Suicide Hotline okay got it
that was a hoop I had to jump through
because I went to the head of the
negotiation team in New York
I said I want to be a hostage negotiator
and oh this is in the book the woman
that you that said turn me down yeah and
so I volunteered on Highline so then
when I get to the bureau's negotiation
School
and they're playing tapes I say to
myself
I've been doing this for a year and a
half I just didn't have a SWAT team
outside
so I've already felt
that it was something that I was going
to be good at and enjoyed
while I was there how was that learning
curve at the suicide hotline
yeah it's really counter-intuitive
um
I had like it's in it's an invisible
skill it's ridiculously effective and
it's completely invisible and you go to
training for that did they train you to
be yeah
not only they train you
but at the at the beginning of the the
training they give you a piece of paper
with 10 10 possible statements to
somebody in a hotline might make
so write down what you think a good
response is they're going to give you
back this piece of paper at the end of
the training
they gave me back the piece of paper at
the end of the training now I I write
like it looks like I write with my feet
my handwriting is very this thing like
there's no way you can fake my
handwriting so they hand me this piece
of paper and I know that's my
handwriting and I remember thinking like
what [__] wrote those responses
that was that was how far they take you
in two months and you don't you don't
even know what's an example of what you
what into you what you instinctively
might think you should say to what you
actually should say
um
so and one call that I did get this guy
calls in and says look look I you know I
just I'm just you know I'm trying to put
a lid on this night I'm trying to put a
lid on this night
now before training I might have said
have you tried watching some TV
uh have you tried working out
like when I'm really stressed I know if
I go get a good workout it clears my
head
or have you tried meditation like
jumping right in to problem solving
that is the wrong way to do it that is
that will prolong the situation
like the speed accelerator
which is neuroscience based I didn't
know at the time
is to deactivate the negatives by
calling them out
so I just say to this guy because I've
been taught to just like call out what
you're in
so I go he sounded frantic so I said Son
for epic
and immediately his voice started coming
down several notches
instantaneously
and that that time like people listen to
that conversation would be like
what he the guy what he just said
seems
unhelpful
however
if I'm watching the person that he said
it to
instantaneously came down
and since you don't see examples of that
in real life
or on the movies or TV on the movies of
TV the guys say look if you tried
working out
and and then in the movies of TV
they'll depict it as the guy as the
other person saying like wow that's a
great idea I'll do that so what's
psychologically going through my head
when I tell you I want to put a cap on
this night I got to put a cap on this
night and you say you say back to me you
sound like you're frantic what's going
through my head that's making me
de-escalate right so um
it's probably a neurochemical reaction
there's a there's and from listening to
huberman and others I'm fascinated by
what finding the science behind it
it's been duplicated in a number of
experiments that if I put you in an fmri
where I can watch the electricity moving
around in your brain
and I show you a picture
that induces some sort of negative
thought and what the picture is it
doesn't matter the experiment's been
done a number of times they might have
shown them puppies in the rain a
starving child in Africa anything that
induce a negative thought and so seeing
the picture they watch
areas in your brain light up that either
for you or predicted in advance where
the negativity in your brain is housed
that bounces around a little bit based
on person but it's essentially
about three quarters of the amygdala and
a couple of other things that are
involved so they watch it light up when
you see the picture
now they just say to you what are you
feeling
just asking you to label it Call it out
Simply call it out
and every time they ask a person to
Simply identify the negative emotion
that they're feeling
the electrical activity in the areas
that had lit up start to diminish
every time
not sometimes not 75 percent of that
time every time now the amount they
diminish changes
which is why I happen to hit the nail on
the head with this guy on a hotline he
starts coming down significantly
sometimes you can call out somebody's
negative emotion and there won't be any
perceivable response it doesn't mean it
didn't work
it means you just need to do it some
more but it happens every time now what
triggers it
is is it a neurochemical response is it
a conscious response is probably some
sort of neurochemical response
but what we learned in hostage
negotiation and in On The Hotline
actually we we do this extremely
aggressively now in all our business
negotiations
like
you know I get some contentions to talk
about
I'm going to call you on a call you on
the phone send you a text sending an
email saying like
okay you're not gonna like what I have
to say is you know it's going to be
harsh this is going to be insulting
and so I I started in a funny kind of
way I started applying this
when I'm running our International
kidnap response
I go to an embassy there's kidnapping
the Philippines I think you read about
earlier
I am unwelcome
because somebody from Washington DC
shows up the locals in the embassy the
message they get is they're screwing up
you either screwing up or you're in it
inadequate somebody from DC is not
welcome
and I'm walking into a hostile
environment every time and because they
were new to it they didn't know exactly
the response they'd usually be doing
something wrong
and I'd walk in I started pointing out
what they were doing wrong
and my partner Chuck Ragini who you uh
you who's in the story
whenever we walk into a room he would
start to Flinch because he knew that I
was getting ready to lay into these guys
and somewhere along the line
I learned to say before I started
criticizing him I'd say this is gonna
sound harsh
and then I criticize him
and they'd be okay
they'd go from being mad
to you know it preempted the negativity
by letting them know what was coming
and I've seen it seen it work on a
regular basis something about it makes
it worse the you could say you could
probably get away with seeing saying
this uh in the Navy and the teams
you could say you know Captain this is
gonna I don't want you to think I'm
being disrespectful and you're probably
not going to get to say the sentence
second sentence second sentence or he's
going to have shut you off
but if instead you said Captain I know
this is going to sound disrespectful
he'd sit there and listen to you
he'd appreciate being warned
and there's something about that
reaction that tiny little shift that I
learned way back on online
so you worked this suicide hotline for a
year I was I was actively on the line
for probably a little over two years two
and a half years I stayed very involved
when um when a First Trade Center kicked
off
then R's follow-on case which was a
larger larger broader conspiracy on a
couple of different groups that were all
linked together
um through the course of that following
year I just didn't have time to
volunteer on a hotline anymore
so this is how this is kind of how you
get started in this negotiation
learning this skill
um and I I kind of told you this before
we started recording we're going to see
all kinds of
overlap between what I talk about from a
leadership perspective
you know there's a lot of skills that
are transformed it's like if you're good
at baseball there's a lot of things that
are going to transfer over to softball
if you're good at wrestling there's a
lot of things they're going to transfer
over to uh you know Jiu Jitsu so there's
a lot of stuff that's really really
similar and there's some some
differences as well but this skill of
negotiation as I read through the book
it's evolved a lot in the last 40 50
years right
um and it you know some of the stuff
that you talk about in the book
you know hostage negotiation used to
mean you know stall them until we get a
chance to assault like that that was
what it was there was a mindset change
that you outlined in the book uh that
occurred around
1971 October 1971 a guy named George
Giff am I saying that right he's a he's
a guy that took a took took a plane took
a plane took hostages on the plane
the plane lands to refuel the hostages
had actually negotiated their own
release
but the FBI got frustrated and shoots
the engine of the plane the guy loses
his mind kills the hostages the FBI gets
sued
and actually loses the lawsuit
so so all of a sudden they realized they
needed to make some adjustments to their
the way they're negotiating right
uh another thing that you kind of detail
in the book is 1979 Harvard starts this
negotiation project
and they're starting to look at
negotiation
theory and practice they're trying to
improve it uh a book ends up coming out
of that the book is called getting to
yes
that was written by Roger Fisher and
William Yuri who were also the
co-founders of that project
and and the theory that they had
was that look the you know people are
emotional and they're animalistic and
they're unreliable
and they're irrational
and you just need to overcome that right
with you know rational logical you know
problem solving mindset
which is
which is actually an idea that doesn't
turn out to work so well because it's a
lot harder to overcome that irrational
emotional animalistic human
so those are some of the uh those are
some of the evolutions that start to
take place
when in the book that you that you run
through
um
and in fact going to the book here you
say you say this about their system was
easy to follow and seductive with four
basic tenants one separate the person
the emotion from the problem two don't
get wrapped up in the other side's
position what they're asking for but
instead focus on their interests why
they're asking for it so you can find
what they really want three work
cooperatively to generate win-win
options and four I'm putting a little
tone on those aren't I sorry uh and for
establish mutually agreed upon standards
for evaluating those possible solutions
so this is like one of those just
detached academic things it was a
brilliant rational and profound
synthesis of the most advanced Game
Theory and legal thinking of the day for
years after that book came out everybody
including the FBI and the NYPD focused
on problem-solving approach to
bargaining interactions it just seems so
modern modern and smart right
so that was what was kind of happening
then you go on to say halfway across the
United States a pair of professors at
the University of Chicago was looking at
everything from economics to negotiation
from a far different angle
they were economists Amos taversky am I
saying that right taversky and
psychologist Daniel Kahneman kaneman
Connor McConnell Kahneman yeah and he
wrote uh Thinking Fast and Slow
together the two launched the field of
behavioral behavioral economics economy
won a Nobel Prize by showing that man is
a very irrational Beast
feeling they discovered is a form of
thinking
as you've seen when Business Schools
like Harvard's began teaching
negotiation in the 1980s the process was
presented as a straightforward economic
analysis there's a period when the
world's top academic economists declared
that we were all rational actors
that means on both sides that means
considering that both people on both
sides are rational and so it went in
negotiation classes assuming the other
side was acting rationally and selfishly
trying to maximize their position
the goal is to figure out how to respond
in various scenarios to maximize one's
own value this mentality baffled
Kahneman who for Year from years in
Psychology knew that in his words quote
it is self-evident that people are
neither fully rational nor completely
selfish and that their tastes are
anything but stable end quote
so there were these two schools going on
with negotiation and one of them took
this kind of logical approach and the
other one realized that you had to deal
with these emotional the emotions was a
way of thinking you're gonna have
something you're gonna have to deal with
and you must have realized that on the
suicide hotlines as well
yeah you know and I didn't really
understand why all I knew is that taking
that approach accelerated things
just complete acceleration and
situations that I thought would have
taken hours and so I just saw and
again Kahneman and doesn't when the
Nobel Prize have like 2002-ish
so just saw that it worked didn't
understand why I didn't really care oh
my first issue has always been what
works
now I understand a mechanism is
important sometimes to ex people need to
understand a mechanism some people need
to understand a mechanism
I care about number one what works
number two secondarily is isn't moral
you know I missionaries and Mercenaries
and mercenaries if it works
missionaries if it follows your basic
moral code if it qualifies on both of
those then I'm good got it
uh
now you go into the book a little bit
about how the FBI sort of started to
adopt this you know the FBI
that they were deep into that book at
one point getting to yes that was what
they were using a lot of guys were using
that but then you know you get Ruby
Ridge up in Idaho you get the the Waco
Texas right these things are kind of
does that these things are
they're very disastrous
um and you throw this in the book I'm
gonna go to the book here I mean have
you ever tried to devise a mutually
beneficial win-win solution with a guy
who thinks he's the Messiah
he was becoming alarmingly obvious that
getting to yes didn't work with
kidnappers no matter how many agents
read the book with highlighters and
hands it failed to improve how we as
hostage negotiators approach deal making
there was clearly a breakdown between
the book's brilliant Theory and everyday
law enforcement experience why was it
that everyone had read this best-selling
Business book and endorsed it as one of
the greatest negotiation texts ever
written and yet so few could follow it
successfully were we morons
uh in 1994 let me fast forward a little
bit from the book and again I'm reading
excerpts for the book the book is
awesome I mean we're hitting some
wavetops so just order the book right
now so you can get all these details in
1994 FBI director Lewis free I know it's
free Louis free announced the form the
the formation of the critical incident
Response Group a blended division that
would combine crisis negotiation crisis
management Behavioral Sciences and
hostage rescue teams
and reinvent crisis negotiation the only
issue was what techniques were we going
to use and you go on to say what were
needed were simply were simple
psychological tactics and strategies
that worked in the field to calm people
down establish Rapport gain trust
illicit verbalization of needs and
persuade the other guy of our of our
empathy
we needed something that was easy to
teach easy to learn and easy to execute
in the early years the FBI experimented
with both new and old therapeutic
techniques developed by the counseling
profession these counseling skills were
aimed at developing positive
relationships with people by
demonstrating an understanding of what
they're going through and how they feel
about it
it all starts with the universally
applicable premise that people want to
be understood and accepted and by the
way again I talked about like leadership
this is exactly what I talk about from a
leadership perspective I mean if you
don't know me at all I'm absolutely
trying to get you to trust me how do I
get you to trust me I put some trust in
you I listen to what you have to say
you're going to listen to me same exact
thing here back to the book listening is
the cheapest yet most most effective
concession we can make to get there by
listening intensely a negotiator
demonstrates empathy and shows a sincere
desire to better understand what the
other side is experiencing exactly why
you listen to your subordinates exactly
why you listen to your peers exactly why
you listen to your boss what are you
trying to tell me boss let me listen
um you know whenever I get asked the
question you know my my team's not
listening to me what should I do
yell louder
it's like no you want your team to
listen to you listen to them be quiet
listen to them hear what they have to
say
uh you go on to say psychotherapy
research shows that when individuals
feel listened to they tend to listen to
themselves more carefully and openly
evaluate and clarify their own thoughts
and feelings
in addition they tend to become less
defensive and oppositional and more
willing to listen to other points of
view which gets them to calm to the calm
and logical place where they can be good
getting to yes problem solvers
so again this is one of the things that
I am talking about all the time with
people
I always say you know if I'm if I want
you to see something if I want to if I
know the truth about something if I've
got some great plan and I want you on
board with my plan the best thing I can
do is not tell you what the plan is is
let you come up with a plan let you let
the truth be revealed to you by you not
not by me right that's my goal
and and you go on to say this whole
concept which you'll learn as the
centerpiece of this book is called
tactical empathy
this is listening as a martial art
balancing the subtle behaviors of
emotional intelligence and assertive
skills of influence to gain access to
the mind of the other person contrary to
popular opinion listening is not a
passive activity
it is the most active thing you can do
once we started developing our new
techniques the negotiating World split
into two concurrents two currents
negotiation as learned at the country's
top school continued down the
established Road of rational problem
solving while ironically we meet heads
at the FBI began to train our agents in
an unproven system based on psychology
counseling and Crisis Intervention
while the ivy league taught math and
economics we became experts in empathy
and our way worked
so that's how the
that's how the shift the shift took
place that's good stuff in that book
well
yeah who the hell wrote that yeah no
it's great and uh telling you I mean I
just I was really uh really stoked to
read it and and got so much out of it
just seeing you know that whole section
right there I mean this is what I I'm
talking to people all the time about
from a leadership perspective you know
the the big difference
the big difference between when I talk
about leadership and if you and I are
negotiating
the big difference is as a leader I
don't really care at the end of the day
what plan we use I just want the best
plan so I I you know if we're gonna
attack a Target
at the end of the day I don't care if we
attack it from the North or from the
south I just want which one is best so I
don't really have I'm not trying to make
you think something I actually just want
to find the best solution now there's a
chance that my solution is the best
there's a chance that your solution is
the best if I go and try and RAM my
solution down your throat what are you
going to do you're going to get
defensive we might not get to the best
solution right if I hang on to my idea
too tightly we're not going to get the
best solution so the main thing that I
can do to help us get to the best
solution not to my solution not to your
solution but just to the best solution
right the best thing for me to do is
listen what you have to say because I
can't make you listen to me I can't
but I can listen to you that's going to
open up your mind it's going to move us
in the right direction so that's that's
probably the the big difference between
the two is that when you're negotiating
you have a goal that you're trying to
get to well here's what I'd add to that
because that description is really the
way we negotiate is we're just looking
for the best deal like you said you're
looking for the best plan yeah like the
the real hard part in negotiating
is
your goal you need to see it merely as a
suggestion
if you get too goal oriented you get
tunnel vision and you miss better
answers never be so sure of what you
want that you wouldn't take something
better yep
and by definition
you're never going to know the best
possible outcome it's not possible
because the other side's holding stuff
back
you're holding stuff back
getting people to accept that
intellectually is often really difficult
with really experienced business people
and I'll say when are you not holding
something back uh budgetary problems
pressures to make the deal pressured and
not make the deal internal politics
personal pressures is there over time
you're not holding something back
and no one ever said
I negotiate and I and I I'm completely
honest all the time nobody ever says
that every people are always holding
stuff back so if you are
they are too
and you're both holding back information
that would change the course of the deal
if revealed that's why you're holding it
back
now so now what happens if you
exponentialize this so to speak
there's an overlap of the unknowns so
it's impossible to know the best deal
going in it's not possible
but very few business people will accept
that it is what it is I know what it is
I'm experienced I know what the outcome
is going to be I know what they're being
driven by like you you know you you are
uh stroking your own ego when you say
stuff like that yeah well that that
means
this stuff is even more in line with
what I talk about I think it's
completely online the other thing that's
interesting is uh you know when you I
forget if we'll cover this today but
I talk to business people and and
occasionally
and it's usually it's very rare
that you know you and I are working at a
company and and we can't come to a
conclusion we can't come to an agreement
you want to do it this way I want to do
it that way and when that happens
and the reason it happens so rarely in
business because if you and I work for
the same company well we both want to
make money we both want to take care of
our client we both want to take care of
the team right like we're ultimately
aligned and so we we're trying to do
something that's going to make us money
and take care of the client and take
care of our team we're going to figure
out a solution that's 99 of the time
one percent of the time
you or don't wanna you either you either
don't want to help the client you
there's someone on the team you don't
want to take care of there's some
something going on where we're truly not
aligned maybe you want to break off and
start your own company so you want us to
fail and if it comes to a point where
I'm saying Chris hold on a second
this is going to make us money it's
going to take care of our team it's
going to take care of the client and and
we can't come to an agreement that means
we're not aligned and you know you talk
about that there are some deals where
you know you want to sell the car and I
want to buy the car but we just can't
there's no there's no possible way that
we're going to do it because you want
you know thirty thousand dollars for the
car and I literally can only pay twenty
thousand dollars it's not gonna happen
right we're not aligned so that does
occasionally happen
um but yeah it's it's it's very
interesting that the Meat Heads at the
FBI were the ones that started trying to
listen and empathize and see the other
people's perspective right right let's
get let's get into the book uh and I'll
tell you what when I was reading the
book one thing that was a little bit
tricky
for me is as I was reading the book I'm
like I want to read about you got you
it's kind of written you know I've
written a couple books too and in my
books
I tell a story the combat Story the
business historian and give the
principal and that's what your book is
too there's a lot of that hey here's a a
combat story an FBI story or a business
story and here's the the negotiating
principle that comes out of it and I
kind of was going back and forth you
know do I read a bunch of the stories
because the stories are great
but I figured since you're here
it'd be great you know I'm sure you'll
tell some of those stories but just to
get into
uh the techniques the techniques the
negotiation techniques that you outlined
in the book and that's kind of what I
decided to do may or may not have been
the right decision we're not sure yet
maybe you'll have to come back just for
pure uh story time but I wanted to get
into the tactics that you talk about
because again I think they're so
prevalent and at you know in in your
intro to the book you talk about
negotiating being
negotiation is life you're negotiating
all the time right so these are things
that you that everybody can use all the
time and and the other thing is kind of
like leadership people think leadership
you either have it or you don't
but really leadership is a bunch of
skills that you can learn right and
negotiation you know how often you hear
oh that guy's a great negotiator
you hear that a lot or that guy is not a
good negotiator negotiator but you what
you don't realize is negotiation just
like basketball or just like playing
guitar there's a bunch of skills that
you can learn there's a bunch of moves
that you can make and once you know
those skills once you know those moves
you can utilize them and so this book
awesome book for pointing out some of
these uh tactics techniques and
procedures so
let's get into a little bit
the first technique that you talk about
or the first one that I'm going to
highlight is called mirroring
yeah and you say mirroring also called
isopraxism is that right it's a lot of
syllables
luckily you've only got in here once I
don't have to say it again is
essentially imitation it's another
neural behavior that humans and other
animals display in which we copy each
other to comfort each other it can be
done with speech patterns body language
vocabulary Tempo tone of voice it
generally it's generally an unconscious
Behavior we're rarely aware of when it's
happening but it's a sign that people
are bonding in sync and establishing the
kind of Rapport that leads to trust
it's a phenomenon and now a technique
that follows a very basic but profound
biological principle We Fear what's
different and are drawn to what's
similar as the saying goes birds of a
feather flock together mirroring then
when practiced consciously is the art of
insinuating similarity
trust me a mirror signals to another
unconscious you and I we're alike
once you're attuned to the dynamic
you'll see it everywhere couples walking
on the street with their steps in
perfect synchronicity
friends in conversation at a park both
nodding their head and Crossing legs at
about the same time these people in a
word are connected while mirroring is
most often associated with forms of
nonverbal communication especially body
language as negotiators a mirror focuses
on the words and nothing else not the
body language not the accent not the
tone or delivery just the words it's
almost laughably simple
for the FBI a mirror is when you repeat
the last three words or the critical one
to three words of what someone just said
of the entirety of the FBI's hostage
negotiation skill set mirroring is the
closest one gets to a Jedi mind trick
simple yet uncannily effective by
repeating back what people say you
trigger this mirroring Instinct and your
counterpart will inevitably elaborate on
what was just said and sustain the
process of connecting psychologist
Richard Wiseman created a study using
waiters to identify what was more
effective
what the more effective method of
creating a connection with strangers
mirroring or positive reinforcement one
group of waiters using positive
reinforcement lavish praise and
encouragement on patreon is using the
words such as great no problem and sure
in response to each order the other
group of waiters mirrored their
customers simply by repeating their
orders back to them the results were
stunning the average tip of the waiters
who mirrored was 70 percent more than
those who use positive reinforcement
so that's pretty amazing it's nuts isn't
it yeah you point out later in the book
that it can feel weird to mirror when
you first start doing it yeah it feels
weird to everybody pretty much yeah it
feels weird to everybody you know I
don't know why that is maybe because it
seems so obvious to the user I mean it's
obvious
yeah you know I feel like saying some
more based on you know what it is
yeah it's just uh
and that's one of the ones again I was
talking about huberman before like if I
could get him to do a ton of experiments
I try this try this try this I gotta
find out this and that that'd be one of
them as to what makes a mirror work so
effectively with so many people
and and it does and then who's attracted
to it I find interesting who's attracted
to it and I also find
it's different circuits in the brain
like the majority of the people on my
team we get really good at labeling
and I find uh as a performance skill
than in myself and others we not might
not mirror enough
and then those that are really attracted
to mirroring and will use it almost
exclusively
okay what isn't that makes you tick that
makes you like that mirroring so much
and I think it's they're attracted to
the Simplicity of it and then they're
not offended
by simple Concepts which actually in
many cases takes a more sophisticated
approach to really like simple stuff
and I'm seeing regularly
people that really mirroring is a
sophisticated skill and if somebody
rejects it off off the off the top of
their head
I think you're worried about appearing
stupid
and if you're so confident in your
intelligence that you got no problem
looking stupid
then you're happy to mirror got it uh
one piece of advice that I give to
people is when Chris rolls into my
office and you're pissed about something
I gotta talk to you right now one thing
I tell people is like cool I get out my
notebook get out my pen yeah and like
what's going on Chris talk to me and to
me that's showing you that I'm listening
to what you have to say and I'm taking
it seriously and it seems like mirroring
is a is another way of doing it right if
you're repeating what I'm saying then
I'm like oh he's paying attention to me
he's listening to me you're proving that
you're listening to the person which
also is a really positive thing never
mind the whole psychological connection
that we're making just the fact that
when I'm repeating what you're saying
back to you it shows you I'm listening
to what you're saying right
I often when I talk about listening
and how important it is
people don't realize how important it is
and I think one of the ways that I use
to explain how important it is I use the
opposite which is if you're talking and
I cut you off
everyone knows that's disrespectful
everybody knows it it's like a sign of
disrespect if someone's talking not jump
in there and cut them off oh you're not
listening me that's being disrespectful
the opposite of that is when I actually
listen to what you have to say and now
we've got a little technique to prove to
you that I'm listening to what you say
I'm going to mirror those last couple
words back to you
so there's no doubt that you got the
words if you repeat them back
nice little technique
uh
moving on a little bit
um again we're hitting the highlights of
this book you got you got to get the
book the book is definitely going to is
definitely going to leave a mark on your
brain
so get the book in a good way yes in a
good way yeah not psychological damage
but in a positive way uh I'm gonna fast
forward a little bit here the language
of negotiation is primarily a language
of conversation and Rapport a way of
quickly establishing relationships and
getting people to talk and think
together
here are some key lessons from this
chapter remember a good negotiation
negotiator prepares going in to be ready
for possible surprises a great
negotiator aims to use her skills to
reveal the surprises she is certain to
find
my note next to that was role play
how often are we role-playing if we're
negotiating
what do you mean so
let's say from a leadership perspective
you know it's you and me we're peers and
I go hey Chris I gotta I gotta go meet
with Echo you know how he's all mad
about you know us cutting his hours I'm
gonna go talk to him right now I know
he's pissed can we run through this a
couple times
so I'm just gonna role play so that way
I think about what could Echo possibly
say you know he might he might get mad
about this he might talk about his
family he might talk about how long he's
been here and I want to kind of have
some contingency plans here right to do
what you said prepare be ready for
possible surprises and actually be ready
to take those surprises and when he says
you know what about my family and I said
well the important thing is Echo I know
we got to give you some last hours right
now but the main thing I want to do is
keep you here the only way you can do
that is if we cut back your hours a
little bit it's hopefully going to be
temporary it should be when the market
picks back up are we in an actual
negotiation see where I'm going here
echo's not in his head he's kind of on
board let's take care of the family what
he's thinking I get more free time
so there you go you know there's another
Point hey now's a little time to make
all those baseball games you got to make
so
that's a point that you made role play
something that we did we do with our
clients all the time right
um if you're with a good role player
right great tool right like if you get
somebody who has
who's dialed in enough emotionally
enough emotional intelligence to make
some good predictions for you it's
probably not bad even if they're not
good at it
you just got to make sure that that's
not exactly the way you expect it to go
down yep yep all right so this is a
possibility not this is how it's going
to happen definitely uh
you say don't commit to assumptions
instead view them as a hypothesis and
use the negotiation to test them
regularly rigorously
to me my note I wrote down on this one
was
the most important characteristic for a
leader to me is to be humble and if
you're not humble you know I go and
think and I'm right you're wrong or I'm
just right it doesn't even matter what
you are because I know I'm right right
this this word of or the way you put it
viewing your ideas as a hypothesis my
plan is it's beautiful
asthma and everyone that a thousand
percent of the tribute to my son Brandon
because he we'd be talking about this
developing it after I left the FBI and
kick any ideas around and he'd have an
Insider he'd say something and I know
that use the word hypothesis in our
vernacular came from him
and it's a good word when you're going
into a discussion with somebody
don't say this is my idea say this is a
just a hypothesis it's the one I came up
with could be right could be wrong let's
see where it's at
uh you say people who view negotiation
as a battle of arguments become
overwhelmed by the voices in their head
negotiation is not an act of battle it's
a process of discovery
the goal is to uncover as much
information as possible
and it goes back to what we already
talked about I'm looking for the best
way of doing it you're looking for a
deal that works best deal best plan
what's the difference right
to quiet the voices in your head make
your soul and all-encompassing focus the
other person and what they have to say
which means we're listening
the most underrated tool of leadership
yeah is listening
uh slow it down
going too fast is one of the mistakes
all negotiators are prone to making
if we're in too much of a hurry people
can feel as if they're not being heard
you risk undermining the Rapport and
Trust you've built
gotta get used to that silence
yeah and you talk about it in here
many many people are uncomfortable
with silence
yeah for a variety of reasons
it's just happened in the last
72 hours last few days
um
what I love about what I do for a living
now is I get an interesting
conversations with people
with Fascinating People that I just like
aspire to be in the same room with so
Ari Emmanuel
you know the the art that Ari from
Hollywood the guy that you know uh the
character on um
entourage is based around right
so he gives me a call he wants to talk
about something and he says you know
speakers Bureau Don Walker runs it we'll
get on the phone with him
cool
so I get on the phone with with Don and
Ari at the same time and Don has done
his homework
but he's one of those guys that's not
comfortable with silence
so fortunately he's so smart about what
he's doing and he's done it for so long
that everything that's coming out of his
mouth is exactly what I'm thinking
however I've I've done a a talk a couple
of times that you get seven to ten
seconds to get somebody's attention or
you lose it
and so he starts out by saying I know I
get seven to ten seconds to get your
attention and he must have talked for
about three minutes and finally Ari goes
that's the longest seven seconds I've
heard in my life because Don just
couldn't stop talking
um
next one put a smile on your face when
people are in a positive frame of mind
they think more quickly and are more
likely to collaborate and problem solve
instead of fight and resist positivity
creates mental agility in both you and
your counterpart all good stuff now you
got you go into this section here and
you talk about it in the book already
you tell and again I'm I'm skipping
the stories that you wrap around these
where people can get the examples of
what you did and where you use these so
get the book so you can get some of
those examples
um three voice tones available to
negotiators number one the late night FM
DJ voice
you selectively to make a point inflect
your voice downward keeping it calm and
slow when done properly you create an
aura of authority and trustworthiness
without triggering defensiveness
number two the positive playful voice
this should be your default voice it's a
voice of an easy going good-natured
person your attitude is light and
encouraging the key here is to relax and
smile while you're talking
number three the direct or assertive
voice use rarely will cause problems and
create pushback
uh
we did a podcast a while ago on
something called Psychological reactants
and what this is is the Instinct that
everyone has that when I tell you to do
something you don't want to do it right
it's just a natural reaction that
everybody has and it causes that's what
allows reverse psychology to work
because when I say oh Chris you can't do
this you go yes I can right when I say
you couldn't paint that fence all by
yourself you go yes I couldn't you go do
it
um so that direct voice
is something to watch out for
foreign
moving on to this next section
and you already mentioned this the the
idea of labeling
uh
you say don't don't feel their pain
label it emotions are one of the main
things that derail communication
once people get upset at one another
rational thinking goes out the window
that's why instead of denying or
ignoring emotions good negotiators
identify and influence them they are
able to precisely label emotions those
of others and especially their own
and once they label the emotions they
talk about them without getting wound up
for them emotion is a tool emotions
aren't obstacles they are a means the
relationship between an emotionally
intelligent negotiator and their
counterpart is essentially therapeutic
it duplicates that of a psychotherapist
with a patient the psychotherapist pokes
and prods to understand his patients
problems and then turns the responses
back onto the patient to get him to go
deeper and change his behavior that's
exactly what good negotiators do
getting to this level of emotional
intelligence demands opening up your
senses talking less and listening more
can learn almost everything you need and
a lot more than other people would like
you to know simply by watching and
listening keeping your eyes peeled your
ears open and your mouth shut
to me about labeling a little bit how we
using it what does it look like
um simple again it seems like it sounds
like it looks like seems like
something's bothering you
seems like you don't know when you're
going to need me
seems like you've given this a lot of
thought
just hanging a label on something it
hits the brain
in a different way than anything else
does
and even questions like
me and another guy Steve show were doing
a lot of stuff with real estate agents
these days got a book coming out four
residential real estate agents in about
two months
what's the name of the book so everyone
can pre-order it the full fee agent okay
and the Agents we've coached for example
you go through an open house you walk
around you look around
and the agent says you're on the way out
the door what'd you see that you liked
basically pretty good question as
questions go starts with the word what
not a great way a good word to start
questioning with calibrated question if
you will
and people stop and think
and they're like ah well you know we're
kind of like the kitchen to give you a
thoughtful answer
same scenario somebody walking out the
door the agent says seems like you saw
some stuff you liked oh yeah look I got
to tell you something we were looking at
the bedroom and we could see our
daughter in there and you know the
backyard is perfect for the way our kids
and like a complete download of what's
going through somebody's brain
like just straight like
from Layman's perspective bypassing the
prefrontal cortex entirely shoving up
uh uh listening device in the side of
your head and hearing what's going on in
your head
another example
in the labels
when you're exhausted when you're tired
it's hard to give a good answer
so I'm on my way back from
a trip to the UAE a couple of months ago
and I'm in Seattle waiting to get on a
plane and I'm exhausted
shoot a text to a buddy
to take care of this now he could have
come back at me with a good question
what makes you ask
to make sure that we're aligned
but instead he texts me back seems like
you have a reason for asking
now I was so tired at that point in time
that I saw the difference seems like you
have a reason for asking I must have
thrown back at him at 10 line text bang
bang bang bang bang bang
and then afterwards I thought if he just
said what makes you ask
I was tired enough that I thought you
know just I'd have texted him back just
do it stop bothering me there's
something about the way the label hits
the brain
that there's a complete mental change in
through response and the amount of
information you get out of somebody
seems like we're danger close on this
one
to the
borderline catastrophic mistake that we
can make which is you come into my
office you're all mad and I look at you
and say calm down you're mad
so the difference here
is
it seems like you're really mad about
this yeah
well it seems like seems like this is
important
because
the great skill works with your boss
also he's one of the students in my
class at Georgetown
boss comes by come on we got to go right
now we got we got something we got to
take care of right now
he called it the boss drive-by
now we is you we got something we got to
do right now that means I got something
for you to do right now
and he's in a really he's loud about it
you know
so this guy gets drug into his boss's
office
and immediately says sounds like this is
important
well the boss is coming at you like that
because it is important which is the
first thing he wants or she wants you to
understand
so if you demonstrate sounds like this
is important right away
boss immediately comes down three
notches starts thinking things through
somebody's angry you know sounds like
this has made you angry sounds like this
is important sounds like this is
upsetting
you want to you want him to come down
several notches
see the lizard brain is out of the
driver's seat and the human brain is
back in right
I got a this book here leadership
strategy and tactics I talk about one of
the tactics I talk about I call it
reflect and diminish which means when
Chris comes into my office and he goes I
can't believe the supply Department
didn't get this stuff here on time
what I do is reflect some of that anger
but I diminish it so I say are you
serious it didn't show up yet
what how much gear is it that you're
missing so immediately I show you that
I'm on your side I show you that I'm
also mad about it but we start moving
towards the solution as opposed to like
well you need to calm down before you
come in here or hey you need to take
ownership of this like cool we can get
there but a little this is like a very
similar idea to reflect and diminish
yeah well and I love that question how
much gear is mission missing because
like on our list of calibrated questions
we hold people almost exclusively to
what and how
and so how feels good to the other side
and through touch on what Kahneman would
talk about it triggers in-depth thinking
so the how question to immediately even
think about the answer let alone answer
it you put them in a completely
different frame of mind which takes all
you know all the steam out takes all the
gas out of the tank takes all the wind
out of the sails whatever you want
of their Reptilian Brain and you you now
got them in a deep thinking mode how's a
great question how is a great question
talk me through uh the next section here
tactical empathy what's uh how do you
how do you how do you use that what does
it mean
um first of all it was we put the word
tactical in front of it
to destigmatize the word
because in common usage the word is
thought of as sympathy or compassion
and it's not
in in usage it's been convoluted and
distorted I can empathize you know I've
been there I feel that way I agree
that was that was not the original
origin of the word
or how it was meant to be applied that
was why I started collaborating with
Harvard in the first place because Bob
manuken wrote in his book
empathy's not even liking the other side
it's not agreement it's not liking
it's demonstrating that you'll
understand
now and people equate to understanding
to agreement in my terrorism days in New
York
we're trying to get Muslims to testify
against other Muslims in open court
and they were shocked by that by a whole
bunch of reasons one of you know if you
want to be proud to be an American
you know have have a uh an Arab Muslim
who's uh in this country just trying to
work really hard
they said to us after the trial you know
when you told us ahead of time this was
about the truth we thought you were
kidding
and having gone through the process we
realized that your system is about the
truth
and so how do we get how do we get those
Muslims to come in and testify honestly
I would sit down with them and I'd say
right off the bat
you think for the last 200 years there's
been a succession of American
governments that have all been
anti-islamic
and they would go
yeah
now that's empathy I never said it was
true
I didn't say I agreed I didn't say I
disagree I took no position whatsoever
on that statement
I say you think this
and I'd nail it on the head and none of
it is that hard when you really really
you know where the other sides come from
you're just scared to say it
like I'd say to these guys and you just
watched
then be shocked
and then dial in with me
having said what was in the back of
their mind
that's all it is and that's and that is
a a similar thing to labeling
uh you say here labeling is a way of
validating someone's emotion by
acknowledging it give someone's emotion
a name and you show that you identify
with how that person feels it gets you
close to someone without asking about
external factors you know nothing about
think of labeling as a shortcut to
intimacy a time-saving emotional hack so
this is similar to oh this is what you
think about a certain subject which now
I'm reading back to you hey you think
that the past 200 years has been
anti-islamic governments
this would be it seems like you're angry
about the way
the Islamic world's been treated
hey that'd be that'd be a great start
a good start like some of this stuff is
ridiculous doing especially talking
about politicians like I'm surprised
more politicians don't don't get this
Mario Cuomo Andrew Cuomo's father Chris
Cuomo's father governor of New York
I saw him addressed a hostile crowd of
African Americans that were waiting for
Winnie Mandela this is just before
Nelson Mandela gets out
Winnie Mandel is doing a world tour
they're keeping the pressure on the
South African government make sure they
let them go
she's in New York
heavy duty African-American crowd almost
all African-American Mario Cuomo isn't
just
not African-American he's Italian which
in New York is a much different dynamic
at the time a couple of black guys had
been chased out of an Italian
neighborhood into traffic and it got
killed by getting hit by cars tensions
with the Italians are very high
Cuomo steps up into a crowd that is just
short of throwing rocks at him before he
said a word
he starts out and he starts going you
see a world that doesn't take your skin
color into account
you see a world that doesn't give you a
chance
because of where you came from and how
they perceive you and he just started
laying out thing after thing after thing
after thing that they were in fact
feeling and thinking
not agreeing with any of it I I
guarantee you before he stepped out on
the stage he probably said to one of his
aides said Watch Me Turn This Crowd
around
they start cheering him inside of about
five minutes
before he's finished with them they
loved him like they were so in favor
because he dialed into them and what
they were thinking and feeling and he
wasn't afraid to say it
and to this day I'm shocked that more
politicians don't do that
because it's not agreement
he takes no position on it whatsoever
this is what you see yeah
yeah it lets that person understand that
you understand at a minimum
this is what we're looking for
um
uh you say here as you try and insert
tools of tactical empathy into your
daily life I encourage you to think of
them as extensions of natural human
interactions as not and not artificial
conversational ticks in any interaction
it pleases us to feel that the other
side is listening and acknowledging our
situation whether you are negotiating a
business deal or simply chatting to a
person at the supermarket butcher
counter creating empathetic relationship
and encouraging your counterpart to
expand on their situation is the basis
of healthy interaction now this is
something I say to people a lot
I say Hey listen you can't pretend to do
this stuff you're not Robert De Niro and
you're not Meryl Streep
so don't pretend to be curious about
them don't pretend just really feel that
way yeah you need to say hey I really
want to learn what you know I really
want to understand what you're thinking
here because if you're trying to act
you're gonna fail most people are going
to fail when they're trying to act right
and I always say intent has a smell so
if you come in there and you're just
trying to butter me up with some little
conversation I'm gonna smell it most
people are gonna smell that I know when
I the reason I know that is because when
I was a young seal I was the youngest
and most Junior guy in my first two seal
platoons so when you know the boss would
come in
we all we you know whatever [__] he
was throwing we'd see right through it
like okay I see what's really going on
here intense gonna have a smell
so
it should be Earnest all this stuff
should be earnest
uh you go on to say some key points here
imagine yourself in your counterpart
situation the beauty of empathy is that
it doesn't demand that you agree with
the other person's ideas
you may well find them crazy but by
acknowledging the other person's
situations you immediately convey that
you're listening and once they know you
are listening they may tell you
something you can use so boom
the reasons why a counterpart will not
make an agreement with you are often
more powerful than why they will make a
deal so Focus first on clearing the
barriers to agreement denying barriers
or negative influences gives them
credence
get them into the open what do you mean
by that
which part uh you and I are talking and
what barriers are you looking at what
barriers
sometimes you're saying barriers the
reason I'm not going to agree to a deal
isn't because I can't find common ground
it's just that there's these barriers
that I have that are that are worse
right right right so first of all uh
kind of three different things there and
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to drive the
state through the heart of common ground
to start with
and this is my theory on Common Ground
first of all the strongest common ground
is usually ethnicity or geography and
geography is more powerful than
ethnicity
like if you and I grew up in the same
neighborhood
um and I don't know what all the
combination of ethnic ethnic groups you
are because like if you were in New York
you'd be one of five and I wouldn't know
which one it is
he's talking to Echo Charles right now
by the way yeah so um but if we grew up
in the same neighborhood like you and I
resonate yeah now if you and I had the
exact same ethnicity and you grew up in
New York City and I grew up in
Mississippi where you're like I don't
know what this dude is talking about
there's going to be some resonance but
geography is stronger now then Common
Ground also why do I want to have common
ground with you
so you understand me
so we say we share core values
you understand where I'm coming from
if so if I just demonstrate that I
understand I'm not going to be one I
don't got to be from your neighborhood
you because what common ground is does
this guy or gal understand me
so that
just show somebody you understand
and Common Ground is unnecessary not a
barriers
um example one of my favorites uh Bob
iger's book the right of a lifetime
he sit down to negotiate what ends up
being the sale of Pixar to Disney
at the time jobs hates Disney
Seas
with hatred for Disney
and when I went to school everybody
writes up that purchases you know it was
obvious it was a great move it was great
for both companies not how this thing
goes down
Hager gets to put in charge of Disney
he reaches out to jobs because he he
knows there's been bad blood I just been
the number two guy at Disney for nine
years
reaches out to jobs
and on some congratulatory thing and
jobs immediately shoots back at him how
long were you Michael's number two
because he he's blaming Michael Eisner
how long were you the number two guy
well this was always going down
not willing to accept any compliment
so Iger says let's talk about this job
says come on down yeah you want to talk
to me come into my backyard go to the
Apple campus I think you're ready to set
up uh jobs wants to work off a
whiteboard
pros and cons
offers the pen to Iger says you go first
now Iger knows how much bad blood there
is here he is not anxious to say a word
and this is in his book
so he says not Steve go ahead
Steve gets up jobs starts writing all
the reasons why not to do it
all the barriers he effectively does
this approach on himself and writes some
nasty stuff about Disney like just short
of out in our profanity insulting your
culture sucks you guys suck everything
about you is horrible your children you
know I mean he everything
he's laying all this stuff out there and
he and he kind of gets done
and he looks to uh hand a pen back to
Iger who's who's not just crestfallen
because he just think feels like he's
gotten the stuffing kicked out of him
and he says well I guess there are a lot
of negatives there
and jobs look back at him and says you
know sometimes
the positive outweigh the negative
because he deactivated all the barriers
they got all the barriers out they got
him out into the open air they cleared
their head by first
discussing and just calling him out
like Bob Iger does not offer a bit of
explanation for any of this
no I can never says but that wasn't true
or but oh yeah no nothing he doesn't say
a word he just lets all the negatives
get out there and when he when he lets
jobs run the full course of the reasons
for not doing it
then jobs is left with the positives
which is in fact the way humans make
decisions you will reconcile in your
head
how do you live with the negatives deal
with them deactivate them
before you decide to do something if you
can reconcile all those negatives as
soon as you do your brain then goes to
the positive
and then the positive picks up this
tremendous amount of velocity
having been Unshackled
from the negatives that's that's it we
do it all the time we do it constantly
I've had this thought a couple times
already during this discussion it's
and it just hit me again
the idea of talking about the negatives
you know right now in the veteran
Community there's a huge you know issue
with uh PTSD and Veteran suicide
and I I've talked about this before when
I've lost my friends in combat
every time I've been a guy that was like
okay you're given the eulogy you're
giving a memorial speech so I had to go
and sit down in the in the pain
and sorrow and write down
what I'm going to say to a crowd of
people you know in a day or two days
and what you end up doing is you end up
thinking through and putting on paper
like you know this terrible situation
um and then you know coming out of the
military when I got out of the military
I was talking to people telling the
Leadership Lessons that I've learned but
in telling the Leadership Lessons that
I've learned you're also talking through
some of the really bad things that
happened
so as I hear you say that look you got
to get those negatives out there I tell
veterans that a lot you know get it
helps when you talk through these things
you know they say that about World War
II versus Vietnam World War II you got
done with World War II what did you do
you got on a ship with a bunch of other
guys that just were in combat and you
sailed back to America for six weeks and
you sat below decks and told stories to
each other about the friends that you
lost and all the stuff that you've been
through
well in Vietnam what did you do you got
done with your tour you got on a plane
for 15 hours and then you got dropped
off in Main Street America you didn't
get to process it you didn't get to talk
about any of this stuff there yeah and
then you got yelled at
so yeah this idea of getting the
negatives out there even though it's
uncomfortable and it is uncomfortable it
sucks no one wants to do it
but if you do it
you start to deal with them you start to
contend with it and I can tell you right
now the more you do it the more you
process it the better you're gonna feel
right so
it's not even just a negotiation thing
this is like a life thing yeah
um
another note you make pause after you
label a barrier or a mirror or mirror a
statement let it sink in don't worry the
other party will fill the silence
getting used to that silence thing label
your counterparts fears to defuse the
power
we all want to talk about happy stuff
but remember the faster you interrupt
action in your counterparts amygdala the
part of the brain that generates fear
the faster you can generate feelings of
safety well-being and Trust same idea
right yeah if we talk about that thing
that is pissing you off or that thing
that's scaring you the minute you let
out of that cage it like loses some of
its power right you know when we work
with explosive we do something called
tamping the explosives which means you
compress that you hold that thing in and
it's going to cause more damage so when
you cover up an explosive it creates a
bigger explosion that's why you see like
a kid puts a firecracker in a microwave
oven and it causes them because the
microwave oven is shut and there's
massive over pressure and it blows the
door you know
150 yards
because you compressed it well it's the
same thing with this fear that you're
talking about you let that thing out let
it breathe
it's going to take the sting off of it
uh that's why you know you just talked
about this with Steve Job list the worst
things that the other party could say
about you and say them before the other
person can
this is the counter-intuitive
counterintuitive what's counterintuitive
about this is I think to myself you know
if I actually tell Chris that it seems
like I'm ripping him off
what if he doesn't think that he
probably won't know and why should I
admit to it it's like he knows
he knows he's thinking that you're
thinking if I'm thinking that hey this
price is probably high he's definitely
thinking the price is high
uh remember you're dealing with a person
who wants to be appreciated and
understood so use labels to reinforce
and encourage positive perception
Dynamics there you go I mean this is
just some awesome techniques here
uh the opening to chapter four here is
kind of a surprise beware of yes and
master no right
at some point their development all
negotiators have to come to grips with
no when you come to realize the real
psychological Dynamic behind it you'll
love the word it's not just that you
lose your fear of it but that you can
come to learn what it does for you and
how you can build deals out of it yes
and maybe are often worthless but no
always Alters the conversation talk us
through that
yeah um
I think I first came across this idea
Jim Camp wrote a book in 2002 called
start with now
and I remember seeing that on a
bookshelf like doing a double take on
like start with no I thought we were
supposed to get the yes yes it was a
magic word
and he had discovered inadvertently
that if you just tell the people it was
okay to say no
that they were more likely to agree just
he's right up front he called the right
to veto and he'd say you know I just
want you to know if before we get into
this you can say no at any time you say
no to me anytime and that and I'll go
away and he made more deals
so accidentally one of my hostage
negotiators in uh Pittsburgh tells me
she says that you know because I'm
making everybody read this book
did I do this now she was going to be
removed removed from the negotiation
team in Pittsburgh
because her boss was jealous
of how much the police department loved
her
so she finds out she's going to get
removed which is going to hurt the
offices relationship with the police
department
but this guy doesn't care because he's
jealous
she sits down with him and she says do
you want the FBI to be embarrassed
now I remember when she first told me
that I remember thinking through at the
moment like I would never have had the
guts to say like that sounds so
manipulative I imagine this guy just
bursting into flames on the spot
guy relaxes he leans back in his chair
you know he Steeples with his hands like
that's what people do when they feel
really good about themselves
laughs and uh he goes no
she says what do you want me to do
and he says well you know stop letting
this stuff interfere with your
investigations now go back to work so he
calls her in to fire her from the team
she walks out no problem
so I'm like there's something here and
then I start thinking about other
conversations I've had uh Lieutenant on
the police department
that I thought gotten this guy's way a
lot because he was
uh over manage them
I remember him saying to me once you
know a Lieutenant's job is to say no
but I thought
no it's not uh Elite you know Lieutenant
is the leader Leader's jobs to encourage
people not to say no
so why is he saying this it makes it
feel good to say no it makes him feel
safe it makes him feel protected
and we start experimenting with
instead of letting people say no what
happens if you actually get them to say
no
like how does that change feelings the
way they react
and it makes such a massive difference
like instantaneous like if it's
important I don't say do you disagree I
say do you disagree
I don't say is this a good idea is this
a ridiculous idea
I don't say you know what I'm never
going for yes I'm always going for no
and you know if I can because I know I'm
all over the place here
I'm on a plane from uh JFK to LA
where it's a red eye
and uh a black businessman sitting next
to me he's kind of loud uh he's got a
he's got a big colorful sweater on but I
just you know not not crazy out there
but I just think you know interesting
interesting cat clearly a businessman
he's got people on his team
because people that are sitting you know
back in economy or walking by and you
know hey boss hey doing and finally but
I hear him on a phone and he's just
try and force people to say yes
and finally I can't take it anymore in
between calls and I tap on the show and
I said look
get them to say no change your questions
you drive me crazy I can't take it
anymore I can I'm hearing you shove this
down people's throats switch from yes to
no and I go instead and again instead of
degree do you disagree instead of would
you do this are you against doing this
and I gave him a quick rundown of how to
make the switch and he's a smart dude
picks it right up really fast
she gets back on the phone
and I also say you know the reason you
should listen to me is because I wrote
this book never split the difference so
just do it
smart dude learnable coachable does it
instantaneously looks back at me says
thanks he says let me introduce myself
my name is Trevor
you may know me by my stage name Busta
Rhymes
[Laughter]
wow okay
you know your hair's a little shorter
right now I didn't recognize you right
off the bat but uh I do recognize that
name
uh
you go on to say no has a lot of skills
no allows real issues to be brought
forth no protects people from making and
lets them correct ineffective decisions
no slows things down so people can
freely Embrace their decisions and their
agreements they enter into no helps
people feel safe secure emotionally
comfortable and in control of all their
decisions no moves everyone everyone's
efforts forward
and there's a there's a a a thing that
you point out here which is important
because you say using this chapter's
tools and daily life is difficult for
many people because they go directly
against one of society's biggest social
dictums that is be nice right especially
because in the book you're like hey
smile be pleasant and and you know
getting people to say no is one of those
things you say we've instrumentalized
niceness in a way as a way of greasing
the social Wheels yet it's often a ruse
we're polite and we don't disagree to
get through daily existence with the
least degree of friction but by turning
niceness into a lubricant we've leached
it of meaning a smile and a nod might
signify get me out of here as much as it
means nice to meet you that's death for
a good negotiator who gains their power
by understanding their counterpart
situation and extracting information
about their counterparts desires and
needs extracting that information means
getting the other party to feel safe and
in control
then while it may sound contradictory
the way to get there is by letting the
other party by getting the other party
to disagree to draw their own boundaries
to Define their desires as a function of
what they do not want
in other words getting them to say no
yeah it's nuts it just it's
of the of the you know the different
skills are counter-intuitive to the to
their own degree
like the extremely strong degree that
getting somebody to say yes makes them
uncomfortable concern worried about what
kind of traps they're walking into was a
hook what have I forgotten
complete different 180 degree tone on
getting him to say no like that the
Comfort level from saying no
and then the ability to think things
through immediately like if I were to
say do you disagree do you disagree
you go no I don't disagree but here are
the following problems and you'd lay
them right out one two three four five
right off the top of your head have no
problem if I'd have said do you agree
and you don't want to say yes I agree
but here are the following problems you
won't do it the second way
because
you would have felt that the mere
utterance of the word yes hooked you
and so then anything that you lay out
after that feels like you're digging
yourself in deeper
but having said no
you don't feel hooked
so now you're going to lay out the next
four or five things that you might need
because you don't feel like you're
digging yourself in deeper
and the next four or five things after
the yes or no are what's critical it's
never never right there it's never at
the point of decision it's really here
are the problems or here's what you got
to accomplish and you got to get past
that
and you get past it freely when people
say no
because they feel safe and protected
they feel no sense of obligation they
don't feel like they're digging
themselves in with each thing they say
after that
I got the that emotion from that you got
an example in the book real common
example
the two the two examples you is now a
bad is now a bad time to talk right
versus do you have a few minutes to talk
right like when someone calls you up on
the phone and says hey do you have a few
minutes to talk right now
I I want to say no but I also kind of
feel like when I say yes like what do we
get but when someone says hey is it a
bad time to talk right now I'm like no
it's not a bad time I'm like okay with
it it's just one of those things
uh the other thing that you got in here
that really aligns a lot with with what
I talk about a lot is um
negotiate in their world persuasion is
not about how bright or smooth you or
forceful you are it's about the other
party convincing themselves that the
solution you want is their own idea
so don't beat them with logic or Brute
Force ask them questions that open past
your goals it's not about you I I say
all the time I've written in these books
make it their idea right how can I make
this their idea and the other thing I
say a lot is the truth doesn't matter if
I punch you in the face with it right I
mean if I punch you in the face of the
truth you're not going to be open to it
you're going to be pissed and you're
going to find a way to defend yourself
and you're probably going to stab me in
the neck with uh your facts from your
perspective so uh with a dull spoon
right stab you in the neck with a double
spoon yeah uh
now we get into this section here
trigger the two or the chapter five
trigger the two words that immediately
transform any negotiation
you say the crisis negotiation unit the
FBI crisis negotiation negotiation unit
developed what is a powerful Staple in
the high-stakes world of Crisis
negotiation the behavioral change
stairway model
bcsm behavioral change stairway model
the model proposes five stages active
listening empathy Rapport influence and
behavioral change
that take any negotiator from listening
to influencing Behavior the origins of
this model can be traced back to the
Great American psychologist Carl Rogers
who proposed that real change can only
come when a therapist accepts that the
client as he or she is
an approach known as unconditional
positive regard the vast majority of us
however as Rogers explained come to
expect that love praise and approval are
dependent on saying and doing things
people consider correct that is because
for most of us positive regard
for the positive regard we we experience
as conditional we develop a habit of
hiding who we really are and what we
really think instead calibrating our
words to gain approval but disclosing
little
so they come up with this thing active
listening that's the first step empathy
all right I kind of see where you're
coming from Rapport now we're starting
to understand each other
influence you're starting to listen to
what I have to say and then behavioral
change you're actually going to do
something different based on the
influence here
uh if you successfully take someone up
the behavioral change stairway each
stage attempting to engender more trust
and more connection there will be a
breakthrough moment when unconditional
positive regard is established and you
can begin exerting influence after years
of refining the staircase and its
tactics I can teach anyone how to get to
that moment
but as Legions of b-school grads weaned
on the most famous negotiating book in
the world getting Diaz have ultimately
discovered you more than likely think
more than likely haven't gotten there
yet if what you're hearing is the word
yes you'll soon learn the sweetest two
words in any negotiation are actually
that's right
that's what you're looking for you're
looking for the other person the person
that you're negotiating with to say
that's right the that's right
breakthrough usually doesn't come at the
beginning of a negotiation it's
invisible to the counterpart when it
occurs and they Embrace what you've said
to them it's a subtle epiphany
so talk to us about that's right
well that's what people say when they're
completely all in on what was just said
like and if you look for it you see it
everywhere and and
one of the great examples that I like to
use is the people that are devoted to
Donald Trump
and my son pointed this out I mean if
that isn't the proof of the that's right
moment
somewhere in a speech or in the
presidential debate when he articulated
something when you bought in completely
you looked at the screen and you pointed
at it and you said that's right
and it's not just Trump it's any
charismatic leader anywhere when the
charismatic leader is articulated
something that you believe is totally
true
and it totally gets you
nobody ever says you're right
they always say that's right
and there's that statement is when when
you were totally bought in on what was
just said and as as and our co-author
tall was one that pulled out uh the
description of it being a subtle
epiphany
tall contributed brilliantly to the book
I mean he brought a lot to the table
besides just being a writer
and so then
um as I was getting more into
Neuroscience I look up Neuroscience the
Neuroscience of epiphany what
neurochemicals do you get hit with
you get hit with serotonin and oxytocin
and oxytocin is the bonding drug
so they hence people bonded to Donald
Trump or any other leader you're you're
bonded to Obama you're bonded to whoever
has uttered the things that you believe
to be completely true there's this it's
a one-way Bond and there's a feeling of
a bond
and then again back to huberman's
podcast you know for me just being
bonded is enough on another one of his
podcasts he points out oxytocin inclines
people to tell the truth
so now not only are you bonded to me
you're more likely to tell me the truth
and then he points out on yet another
podcast serotonin
the feeling of satisfaction
which means you're not as demanding
so if I can get a that's right out of
you you're going to bond to me you're
going to tell me the truth and you're
going to make fewer demands what else do
I want
yeah the the example and again the
details on the book are are outstanding
but the example that you give goes back
to the thing that I opened up with you
had sabaya this Mastermind terrorist
and you were in negotiations with them
and you're actually working through a
translator
and the translator was a hard ass you
know pretty much let's we need to go at
him type of attitude and you kind of
convinced him over time to take a less a
more indirect approach
and and eventually the The Negotiator
kind of read back
hey look you've been oppressed for this
long the Spanish came here they
converted your people against their will
and you've been suffering underneath
this government and sabaya says that's
right
and that's what changes it that's what
changes his attitude yeah yeah and if I
can couple of tangents because yeah you
know we
that was also when I was working with
mcraven okay not Admiral but Captain
McCray
and he was he was phenomenal and he he
shared he created the hostage working
group in the National Security Council
his leadership you know what a great guy
to work with I can remember in
particular when we're working that case
and wanted to follow it on
like there was some stuff
that the US government was very nervous
about
and you needed a guy
um who stood up properly for everybody
and for the right thing if you will and
I can remember being at one meeting in
particular
uh uh Captain mccraven mcraven I don't
mean to be disrespectful I'm sure it
sounds disrespectful just call him a
craven but uh mcraven stands up and he
says you know what I'm not going to stop
talking about this until somebody tells
me to sit down and shut up
and they're gonna have to tell me twice
and I remember thinking that's the guy I
want
talking to the White House that's the
guy that I want to talk in the
Department of State
and we're in the midst of that Shilling
case and the last thing that we need
when we're
in a forward operating base
is any sort of
um insecurity indecision from Washington
DC and when you're out there on the
front lines having a guy like Captain
Bill mcraven Admiral bill mcraven
holding things together back in
Washington DC it's just a ridiculously
reassuring feeling to have he was a
great guy no doubt about it that's
that's awesome uh
there's a big difference and you pointed
out in the book
there's a huge difference and you
mentioned it but I just want to cover it
again just to make sure people catch
this
there's a huge difference between that's
right and you're right
because you're right anyway here's a
good way to here's a good way to
translate this you know you're talking
to your wife
and you know you say something she goes
oh you're right
that is not what we're looking for that
means she wants you to shut up and she's
going to carry on and you haven't come
to any kind of conclusion
uh so there's a big difference getting
someone to say you're right in fact
there's a lot of times where
that's in an increase in hostilities
that just means they're looking for
another way to attack you
yeah and they haven't quite got it yet
but they're they're waiting they're
laying in weight and it's if they've
given you your right
um you got problems
foreign
be careful with that one look for that's
right
uh
next section bend their realities
and and
you get into this here don't compromise
which is a interesting thing we're going
to talk through
the win-win mindset pushed by so many
negotiation experts is usually
ineffective and often disastrous at best
it satisfies neither side and if you
employ it with the counterpart who has a
win-lose approach you're setting
yourself up to be swindled of course as
we've noted previously you need to keep
a Cooperative Rapport building apathetic
approach the kind that creates a dynamic
in which deals can be made but you have
to get rid of that naivete
because compromise splitting the
difference can lead to terrible outcomes
compromise is often a bad deal and a key
theme will hit in this chapter is no
deal is better than a bad deal even in
kidnapping yes a bad deal in kidnapping
is where someone pays and no one comes
out
to make my point on compromise let me
paint an example a woman wants her
husband to wear black shoes with a suit
but her husband doesn't want to know he
prefers brown shoes so what do they do
they compromise they split the
difference they meet halfways halfway
and you guessed it he wears one black
shoe and one brown shoe is this the best
outcome in fact No in fact it's the
worst possible outcome either of the two
outcomes black or brown would have been
better
I'm here to call [__] on compromise
right now we don't compromise because
it's right we compromise because it's
easy and because it saves face we
compromise in order to say that at least
we got half the pie
still to his Essence we compromise to be
safe most people in negotiation are
driven by fear or by the desire to avoid
pain too for you are driven by their
actual goals so don't settle here's a
simple rule never split the difference
Creative Solutions are almost always
preceded by some degree of risk
annoyance confusion and conflict
accommodation and compromise produced
none of that you've got to embrace the
hard stuff that's where the great deals
are and that's what negotiators do
amen
[Laughter]
it's quiet say Amen what point did you
realize that was the title of the book
tall came up with that
um the original title was killer deals
we started working with tall Brandon and
I my son Brandon
um uncredited co-author of the book
and Tulsa's right so we're gonna we'll
start with killer deals and at some
point in time the the proper title of
the book will occur to me and I'll tell
you what it is now you're free to
disagree
but I can tell you when I get deeply
into this enough
it I'll give you the title and probably
about halfway through the whole writing
process
was when he said titles never split the
difference it says it's the essence of
what you guys are talking about it if
you completely understand it and
understand why he says that's what the
title is
and we're like
you got it that's right
[Music]
yeah he came he told came up with it
probably about halfway through the
writing process now how does that we're
going to get into I think I'm gonna
cover it but the uh the Ackerman
approach right
now in the Ackerman approach you're
shooting for a specific number
right
and you know you're kind of compromising
to get to that number nope
why if you shoot for a specific number
why is that okay as long as you get your
number but
that that's my number
uh meaning you wanna you wanna sell me
this car for ten thousand dollars I only
want to give you seven thousand dollars
my first offer is a lowball offer right
and then I come up
well my first offer 65 of what I want to
pay then I go 85 95 then 100 of what I
want to pay right so I guess we didn't
we didn't split the difference
no it's not and there's also a very
specific
um uh sort of rationale behindi offers
each offer has to be
effectively half as much as the previous
increase right you gotta you gotta
always have diminishing increases the
other side is going to feel like they're
beating you into a position they're
going to be very gratifying for them
uh
deadlines
you talk about here time is one of the
most critical crucial variables in any
negotiation the simple passing of time
and it's sharper cause causing the
deadline or the screw that pressures
every deal to conclusion
whether your deadline is real and
absolute or merely a line in the sand it
can trick you into believing that doing
a deal now is more important than
getting a good deal deadlines regularly
make people say and do impulsive things
that are against their best interests
because we all have a natural tendency
to rush as a deadline approaches
yeah not only Rush is the deadline
approaches
but not rush at all until it's looming
no like and people lose track of that
it's the process
and at deadlines are really just
designed to kick the process into gear
but human beings being what they are
if you give somebody a deadline of
Friday
don't expect to get into any kind of
conversation before Thursday
yeah I've done a lot of deals like on
the way to the airport we're on our way
out and that's when the discussion
actually starts right
not optimal right uh skipping ahead a
little bit in the book The F Word why
it's so powerful when to use it and how
the most powerful word in negotiations
is fair right as human beings we're
mightily swayed by how much we feel we
have been respected
people comply with agreements if they
feel they've been treated fairly and
lash out if they don't
once you understand what a messy
emotional and destructive Dynamic
fairness can be you can see why fair is
a tremendously powerful word and you
need to use it with care in in fact of
the three ways that people drop the
F-bomb only one is positive the most
common is a judo-like defensive move
that destabilizes the other side this
manipulation usually takes the form
something like we just want what's fair
think back to the last time someone made
this implicit accusation of unfairness
to you and I bet you have to admit that
it immediately triggered feelings of
defensiveness and discomfort these
feelings are often subconscious and lead
to irrational concession
the second use of the F-bomb is more
nefarious in this one your counterpart
will basically accuse you of being dense
or dishonest by saying we've given you a
fair offer
the terrible little jab meant to
distract your attention away from a
distract your attention manipulating to
giving in
if you find yourself in this situation
the best reaction is to Simply mirror
the F that has just been loved that you
fare you'd respond pausing to let the
words power do to them what it was
intended to do to you
following that with a label it seems
like you're ready to provide evidence
that supports that which alludes to the
opening of their books or otherwise
handing over information that will
either contradict their claim to
fairness or give you more data to work
with than you had previously right away
you declaw the attack the last use of
the f word is my favorite because it's
positive and constructive
it sets the stage for honest and
empathetic negotiation
here's how I use it early on in the
negotiation I say I want you to feel
like you're being treated fairly at all
times so please stop me at any time if
I'm being unfair and we'll address it
simple and clear and sets me up as an
honest dealer
with that statement I let people know
it's okay to use the word with me if
they use it honestly as a negotiator you
should strive for reputation of being
fair you represent your reputation
precedes you let it precede you in a way
that paves success
I when I read all that I was like oh we
all it seems like human beings have this
sort of natural we're just raised that
fairness is a big thing for us
and you know what I what I sometimes
when I think of when I can't quite make
a connection
I think of the opposite and what that
triggers in people so what's like the
Epic
insult that guy's a cheater right that
guy's a cheater oh yeah you won but he
cheated
you know you hate that guy you don't
want to be that guy when someone says
you cheated you get all defensive
so it's the same thing here or this this
F-bomb when it gets dropped on you and
someone goes hey we just want what's
fair we need I'm not being fair and it
can trigger you to making a deal you
shouldn't have made
a lot and the amount of time like there
it's rare that in a a negotiation that
has any sort of contentiousness to it at
all
the word will always come up
I mean it's a great manipulative device
and people often say it
added defensiveness
but for the same for the same ends you
know get the aside to change your mind
providing no evidence whatsoever as to
why they should
that's not fair
yeah exactly yeah yeah that's uh you see
it and usually it's it's when the table
hasn't gotten turned on somebody in an
unexpected way
that's when they'll drop the word what
does that look like
um
a person I know who's an eminently Fair
person
was in a real estate negotiation right
after the housing market where they were
at drops substantially
and they got the buyer to increase the
offer above Market
by simply saying we just want what's
fair
now the person that used this phrase
had gotten the tables turned on them by
a drop in a market
so it wasn't even the buyer's fault but
I didn't do anything
buyers following the market
so this person out of simple
defensiveness having had the tables
turned on them
they felt that it was an unfair series
of circumstances
now is is that the buyer's fault
buyers are spying in a real estate
market that is dictated by the Dynamics
of the market
and that was the first time it really
jumped out at me
and then I started looking for it across
the board
because a person who told the story got
the buyer to raise the price
and I remember thinking like that wait
wait as an innocent bystander here that
you know that's not fair
there's no fairness there and I thought
if a good person can do this and change
completely change the Dynamics in a
relationship in the negotiation how
often does it come up and then you start
looking for it and you see it over and
it is so effective
that the the manipulators have seen the
good people use it and change the
Dynamics that they've gotten really good
at using it to cover up manipulative
Behavior
watch out for that one
got a section in here bend their reality
you start going to some of the
methodologies of that anchor their
emotions to bend your counterparts
reality you have to start with the
basics of empathy so start out with an
accusation with an accusation audit
acknowledging all of their fears by
anchoring their emotions in preparation
for a loss you inflame the other side's
loss aversion so that they'll jump at
the chance to avoid it you talk about
loss aversion people are people don't
want to lose right and and this uh
accusation audit is sort of what Steve
Jobs put up on the board when he did it
himself right right
um Eiger could have done it if he
if he had stepped up to the thing and
said well you're probably going to say
this and this and this but he got Steve
Jobs do which is even better
uh but you anchor those emotions
the other thing you say is uh let the
other guy go first
most of the time
I suggest you let the other side anchor
monetary negotiations the real issues
that neither side has a perfect
information going on the table this
means if you don't know enough to open
up with confidence so this is what we
hear all the time in negotiations you
know you don't say the number first how
much do you want how much will you give
me for the car well what do you think
it's worth like we do this around and
around right yeah uh what are the
disadvantages advantages of opening
or giving the number
well very much as a general rule I'm I'm
going to want the other side to show the
number first because it's information
it's gonna it's gonna tell me
it's going to tell me data it's going to
tell me mindset where you're coming from
it's going to tell me a lot none of
which am I getting
if I go first
so as a general rule we don't go first
again a general rule it's at some point
in time to keep from going round and
around around I'm going to throw a
number out now I'm going to characterize
it before I throw it out
and if it I'm going to say this is a lot
when when we quote prices for our
coaching first of all our coaching is
more expensive if you can find
negotiation coaching anywhere which is
very hard to find
we're going to charge you more than
anybody else this
so I'm gonna I'm gonna say that
I'm gonna charge you more than anybody
else does
somebody somebody wants to bring me in
for a talk
I'm gonna I'm I'm gonna be so expensive
and we're going to quote you a
heart-stopping price
and then you get that causes you to
reflect on your value
it causes you uh to run the numbers one
or two things you're gonna you're gonna
ask me what the number is
and you're either going to say hey
well he said it was expensive
or you're going to say wow it's not as
bad as I thought it was going to be
and then we don't bargain
so if I Gotta Throw a number I I like to
refer to as I never throw the number out
naked
if I and if otherwise I want to know
where you're coming from I also want to
give you a price that you want
because price is a term
and I need to hit the sweet spot on your
price
if I go too high
you're not going to over deliver you're
going to feel like you undervalued
yourself and you're going to do the same
amount of work if I pay you too much I
found that out the hard way
if I go too low
you're going to do a lousy job
so what I need what I really want
besides just throwing a number first
I want to know what number do you think
a good number is
that you're going to work really hard
for
and feel like you earned your money
and not change
that you just undervalued yourself in
the past and now now all of a sudden I'm
worth this much more money which means
you're not going to put in extra effort
you're also talking here about if people
are are stuck on the money you can start
talking about other things right the
non-monetary terms right so like if
you're negotiating for a job you start
talking about things that don't have
anything to do with money right and that
can be a good way to start to move the
conversation forward
the uh
this is just interesting psychology the
biggest thing to remember and when you
start when you when you do get to
numbers you say the biggest thing to
remember is that numbers that end in
zero inevitably feel like temporary
placeholders guesstimates that you can
easily be negotiated off of but anything
you throw out that sounds less rounded
say 37
263 dollars
feels like a figure that you came to as
a result of thoughtful calculation
such numbers feel serious and permanent
to your counterpart so use them to
fortify your offers
yeah it's nuts right I mean it's just
that's Voodoo yeah it is so true and
it's just complete voodoo
Ah that's and and yet go look at the
prices in a store
right we see examples of it everywhere
they're all
9.95 or whatever and there's a
psychological thing to be you know ten
dollars seems like a ton of money 9.95 I
can afford all day right right right
yeah well the original magic one that I
love like iTunes
99 Cents for a song
back when Napster and you could get all
your music for free
like jobs and apple like let's put a
number on this
that seems so small and it's not it's
not a round number
and suddenly
people were paying for music again 99
cents
still 99 Cents for a song isn't it some
songs yeah I guess it's all like
streaming and all this stuff now you
don't really buy well actually I don't I
buy like the whole thing whatever that
is 129 sometimes
so they jacked the prices some some yes
some key points all negotiations are
defined by a network of subterranean
desires and needs don't let yourself be
fooled by the surface once you know
that the Haitian kidnappers want to
party want party money you'll be better
you'll be miles better prepared and
there's a whole section in here about
that
about these Haitian kidnappers you did
you worked all kinds like dozens of
cases of these Haitian kidnappers one of
the things you've identified as they
would like kidnap early in the week they
wanted that money by Friday so they
could go out and party
and so how much do they need to have a
great party that weekend that's sort of
the number that you would end up looking
for I mean it's awesome uh splitting the
differences wearing one black and one
brown shoe don't compromise meeting
halfway often leads to bad deals for
both sides approaching deadlines entice
people to rush the negotiating process
do impulsive things that are against
their best interests we talked about the
f word
you can bend your counterparts Reality
by anchoring his starting point before
you make an offer emotionally anchor
them by saying how bad it will be when
you get to numbers set an extreme anchor
to make your real offer seem reasonable
or use a range to seem less aggressive
the real value of anything depends on
what Vantage Point you're looking at it
from
and last people 10 people take more
risks to avoid a loss than realize again
make sure your counterpart sees that
there's something to lose by inaction
that's why the
that's why the website says today only
yeah you'll miss out
uh
you got a section in here that's about
fast forward a little bit calibrated
Quest calibrate your questions
and we we kind of discussed this earlier
if we were recording or not but I talked
about asking Earnest questions as a
leader you're asking Earnest questions
and you've got this a little bit similar
approach but uh different verbage here
calibrated questions are not just random
requests for comment they have a
direction once you figure out where you
want a conversation to go you have to
design the question that will ease the
conversation in that direction while
letting the other guy think think it's
his choice to take you there that's why
I refer to these questions as calibrated
questions you have to calibrate them
carefully just like you would calibrate
a gun site or a measuring scale to
Target a specific problem the good news
is that there are rules for that first
off calibrated questions avoid verbs
like can is are do or does
these are closed-ended questions that
can be answered with a simple yes or no
instead they start with a list of words
people know as reporters questions who
what when where why and how those words
Inspire your counterpart to think and
then speak expansively but let me cut
that list even further it's best to
start with what how and sometimes why
nothing else who when and where will
often just get your counterpart to share
a fact without thinking and why can
backfire regardless of what the language
what language the word why is translated
into it's accusatory
there are very rare moments when this is
to your advantage the only time you can
use y successfully is when defending
when defensiveness that is created
supports the change you are trying to
get them to see why would you ever
change from the way you've always done
things to try my Approach as an example
so
I found this very useful
because
you know I I often talk about something
uh from a military perspective called
the indirect approach which means I
don't want to attack you head on I want
to you know I want to attack you from a
flank where you're not defensive and
this applies to everything it applies to
leadership it applies of approaching
people applies to you know if you've got
an ego which everyone does and I attack
your plan that means I'm attacking your
ego you're gonna get defensive so
you know oftentimes it's in order to get
around your ego I'm going to ask you
Earnest questions about the situation
but the key thing that you've got here
is I don't say well why do you think
this is a good plan
because that's an accusatory question
right instead I'm a better question
would be
hey can you help me understand the
outcome that you're looking for with
this plan
and all of a sudden we've got we've
taken away any possibility that you can
see that I'm accusing or attacking your
plan which thereby is attacking your ego
uh how did you come across this
calibrated questions idea
um Camp spoke 2002 he called them
interrogatives the reporters questions
in the FBI we called them just
open-ended you know the list what who
won't win where how and why
and I noticed that he leaned heavily on
one in particular which was
the biggest challenge you face
now I didn't realize it at the time
um
first of all it's a white question
what's deferential people like to be
asked what to do
secondly now we now know the Black Swan
method what is principally designed to
uncover problems
what's the biggest challenge you face
what gets in the way
I'm coaching some dentists recently
people are balking at how much their
dental work is going to cost
the question is what happens if you do
nothing
you know to what questions deferential
and so then be begin to to look harder
at the questions I thought that was the
only lab overlap between business and
hostage negotiation at the time
then then the Burnham case in the
Philippines
um it goes bad train wreck all the way
around
and somebody got Proof of Life on our
hostages in the midst of that case and
I'm just remember it blew my mind
because a hostage was overheard on a
phone and I'd never gotten a hostage on
the phone
so between how does somebody get a
hostage on a phone and who the heck is
getting Proof of Life on our hostages
like there was more than one buyer like
I didn't know what to do with this
so the case case is an ongoing 13-month
long train wreck a lot of people died
including two out of two out of three of
the total Americans that were taken
listen to a drug dealer kidnapping in
Pittsburgh a few months afterwards drug
dealer on drug dealer one drug dealer's
got the other drug dealer's girlfriend
hostage
who do you go when somebody important to
you has been kidnapped even if you're a
drug dealer you go to the FBI
so our hostage negotiators are riding
around listening to the drug dealer talk
to the other drug dealer
and just on his own he goes
hey dog
how do I know she's okay
and the change in the tone of voice
the kidnapper drug dealer went from
thinking he was in charge to being
having lost all control of negotiation
and not knowing it at the time it was
just a high question
so then we changed all of our
negotiation kidnapping strategy to how
and what questions just hammering them
with how and what questions because you
want to you want to test some test it
out to kidnapping
and finally I'm coaching another
kidnapping in the Philippines coaching a
brother his brother's been grabbed by a
serial killer
lone kidnapper only time in my entire
experience
with one kidnapper they're always
operating gangs and the guy was a we
found out after a fact because we we
caught him
he was a multiple kidnappings and it
killed at least well
didn't have the evidence that he killed
a hostage in another case just that
Ransom was paid and the hostage never
appeared so there's only one conclusion
we're coaching coaching a brother again
a good guy who would learn pick up fast
how and what questions how and what
questions how and what questions
and at one point in time the kidnapper
wants a daily per diem to keep the
hostage alive
which we we gotta fight over that
because it's a way to test Financial
Resources not to keep the hostage alive
that's the family's resources
so on his own the brother says
when we run out of money paying the
daily amount
what's gonna happen
and there's a silence and this serial
killer on the other end of the phone
says
it'll be all right
my negotiators in country call me there
we think we got a positive breakthrough
today but we're not sure what it is
and they told me that I said this guy
just promised never to kill hostage
like I had no idea that it was a lone
guy I thought we were just talking to
the boss
didn't know he was a killer it was
another case where he chopped the
victim's ear off sent the ear and video
of him chopping here off to the victim's
company they got paid I knew about that
I've been told for a variety of reasons
I'd heard about that I didn't know it
was this guy
take him completely out of his game
with a version of what question saw
another one took another guy completely
out of his game with a version of the
how question
in a
Dynamic where you'd have said we had no
leverage if you thought in terms of
Leverage but you got influence
how do you get influence through
deference
and that's when we really began to dial
in collectively principally my son
Brandon and I another guy Derek gone
very involved in the development of our
thinking
and we really narrowed it down to how
and what
is a way to really get the upper hand in
a negotiation
um
fast forward a little bit here you got a
couple things that are awesome points
don't try to force your opponent to
admit that you are right
aggressive confrontation is the enemy of
constructive negotiation I always say
when you're dealing with someone give
them an out you know you just give them
an out you can say ah you know it seems
like this is the best way to do it but I
know you you're smart on this stuff too
does it make sense and they go yeah you
know go ahead and do it that way you
know they you give them an opportunity
that they don't have to say I was I'm
wrong you're right go do it your way no
never do that
and the other one
again this isn't just for negotiation
this is for Life bite your tongue when
you're attacked in a negotiation pause
and avoid angry emotional reactions
instead ask your counterpart a
calibrated question
just such a such a solid move that will
keep you out of trouble
you want to say something back you know
I I actually go I tell people you know
someone starts attacking you or someone
someone starts getting aggressive with
you you know take a step back kind of
Nod your head show them that you're
listening
don't say anything back to him instead
ask him a question you
way to go forward
uh
the 7 38 55 rule
and two famous studies on what makes us
like or dislike somebody UCLA psychology
Professor Albert
mayhabrian right totally murdered that
one you're not Persian I'm not you know
how to say that if you're a Persian
sorry there Albert we'll call him Albert
Dr Albert uh created the 738-55 rule
that is only seven percent of a message
is based on the words while 38 comes
from the tone of the voice and 55 from
the speaker's body language and face
while these figures mainly relate to
situations where we are forming an
attitude about someone the rule
nonetheless offers a useful ratio for
negotiators you see body language and
tone of voice not words are our most
powerful assessment tools
uh
important to remember that important to
pay attention a lot of us a lot a lot of
people
their your face gives away so much and
it doesn't even matter what you're
saying the look that you have on your
face is just just giving away the way
you feel and it doesn't even matter what
your words are
did you feel like you had to learn to uh
you know control your facial expressions
I got my my business partner and my
friend Leif Babin
you know he when he when we first
started working together when he was
pissed you knew it and so did everybody
else it was like his face would turn red
you could see how mad he was
and you know over time you know as you
know he started to realize that that
didn't help him
started to learn how to not do that is
that something that you see people have
to recognize and then get get themselves
trained up on
yeah depending upon the person there's
underlying currents
um
so it could be for different reasons the
short answer is yes
and the the longer answer is how do you
align your thinking in the moment
a little bit of what you mentioned
earlier like if you're really interested
in what the other person is saying and
then you worry about evaluating after
the fact you don't have to worry about
the look on your face
as a matter of fact if you're really
interested
the more interested you look the more
they're going to talk
so if you can separate the two things
out from evaluating judging what
somebody said to just being making sure
you fully understand then facial
expressions are not a problem
now the people that have a problem with
them and you know it's you you're your
guys faces turn red making all that's a
characteristic principally
of the assertive negotiator who can't
wait to disagree
and is holding it in
the highly analytical type
you know the people that seem completely
emotionally detached
when they think you're not looking
they reveal everything and and like
their facial expressions their their
body language I mean they almost
sometimes they look like they're
twitching
and so if if you know who who's highly
analytical if you're faced with a team
of people
do not talk to the analytical guy or gal
keep an eye on them
you got to kind of watch them out of the
corner you're right because they're
going to be rolling their eyes and
they're going to be sneaking peeks at
people at moments I mean like they are
they're the most honest most unguarded
body language you ever saw in your life
if they don't think they're being stared
at yeah
uh let me ask you this so I've been
talking about leadership you're talking
about you write about negotiation how
much interaction because there's also a
ton of similarities with uh
interrogators how much interaction did
you have with interrogators I mean I
obviously worked with a ton of
interrogators in a bunch of different
organizations
how much how much work did you do with
interrogators a fair amount and there
there's probably about three schools of
thought out there
um the the Great
well the bad ones are just Brute Force
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna make you
uncomfortable physically or emotionally
and I'm gonna try to force something out
of you and that's that's just
that just doesn't work it's kind of it's
counterproductive if you if you only
care about what works then you won't be
harsh because it doesn't work
now the other two that are left there's
one thing called the listing information
which uh they're a fair amount of
interrogators out there that like it
and they they want to get you into a
very short-term mindset get you to say
things that you know to be against your
interests
the problem is if you're getting
somebody into a short-term mindset
they're going to come a point in time
when they regret saying it to you and
you're going to lose their cooperation
everything's going to fall apart so it
has a shelf life
now the Rapport based people
those are the magic magicians
that make cases nobody else can make or
make deals no one else could make
and the other side still wants to talk
to him
like when I left surveillance in New
York
and went inside to investigate what we
were talking earlier became an inside
you know uh open investigator
I was surrounded by guys
that had gotten cooperation from
Witnesses voluntarily that people would
just say like I got no idea how that guy
got that cooperation One agent in
particular his name was Larry whack
and even even on the task force people
admired how he got people to cooperate
because he was he was he developed
Rapport poor relationships with people
even if he had a hammer the Rapport on
the relationship you know the belief
that we will always have be able to talk
to one another
as opposed to me tricking you into a
short-term mindset which at some point
in time you're going to feel betrayed
like the rapport-based approach to deal
making interrogation wins every time the
same thing with leadership we might as
well throw leadership in there as well
you know the time I say well you know if
you don't do this I'm gonna fire you or
whatever it'll work for that task but
eventually you're looking for another
job
uh so yeah those those similarities
building relationships across the board
so you just mentioned the analyst that's
one type of person and you've got a
whole section in here about not only you
what kind of negotiator are you because
you got to know yourself but then also
how are you going to interact with these
people you got the analysts that you
talked about which is methodical
diligent they're not in a big rutch you
talked about them uh tell me about the
accommodator just
the so being an assertive
the accommodators this weird animal they
knew the analysts nor the asserters can
really figure out
but the accommodators really is a very
hope-based person
and very focused on
that the moment is Pleasant
and then if if the moment is pleasant
and we hope hard enough
then everything will be fine
now when we wrote when we wrote the book
we said the accommodator was focused
principally on the relationship having a
positive relationship
and that's pretty close to True like
they want the relationship to be
positive but
you know we worked with
people that would see a train coming at
us
uh rhetorically
uh Federal figuratively not literally
there's a problem coming at us
this person was on a team and we had a
training and all the books that were
supposed to be that were gone this guy
knew about it for days
at the last minute tells us none of the
manuals were here
because he'd been and we're like you
know this is the train is getting ready
to hit us we've been here for three days
you haven't said a word for three days
that's not relationship focused because
I'm standing on a railroad track and you
see a train coming my way and you're not
warning me so you know this relationship
is coming to a close
and then we realized in hindsight
and we see it constantly
they're hoping something good happens at
the last minute everybody's saved
my colleague Derek would say you know an
accommodator will walk you into a
Minefield knowing it's a Minefield
hoping you don't step on a mine
and so the accommodators I think are the
source of why in a business world people
often say hope is not a strategy
because the accommodator will go with
hope alone
and it'll work out hope alone is
probably good
somewhere between 20 and 45 percent of
the time
maybe that maybe that's being
generous maybe 20 of the time and
they're going to remember the 20 percent
and ignore the 80 when the world turned
into a disaster
so the accommodators are really are very
positive people
they're very upbeat
and they're very hope focused which is
in and of itself it's not a strategy
it's it's a necessary element you got to
be hopeful it's going to work out it's
what it is is inadequate
now simultaneously
people love dealing with somebody like
that
so we'll see on a regular basis the
accommodators will make more deals
overall than anybody else will
but that'd be mostly really sloppy deals
that are nowhere near as profitable for
either side as they should have been
because they simply hoped that things
would fall into place
and then the last one which I think you
just self-identified as sorry
assertive so what's the deal with the
assertive negotiator just honest I'm
just being honest with you you know I'm
I'm saving you a lot of trouble because
I want you to be honest with me so I'm
gonna be honest with you
that was stupid that's a dumb idea
that's never gonna work you didn't think
this thing you know the the assertives
anybody that describes themselves as
simply open and honest
and it's always a punch in the face it's
always
just that approach like you the other
side's got to know where you're coming
from you do have to be honest but it's
how you deliver it and the assertives
are the typically the worst at making
you I had I had my partner once tell me
dealing with you is like getting hit in
the face with a brick
and I remember thinking like
how could that be I'm the nicest guy I
know
yeah no that's like what I thought what
I talked about earlier like me punching
you in the face with the truth is not a
good way to get you listen exactly Echo
always brings up the example of the
person that says you know I'm just a
direct person but I gotta tell you you
were totally screwed up and again
there's not a lot of people like oh
thank you for being that direct person
and telling me how jacked up I am
usually oh look do you occasionally get
someone that loves to get coached and
love to get told what they yeah you get
some people a lot of times it just
defends them so that is so so when you
take these three different personality
types negotiator types are we looking to
blend yes that's what the goal is
each type has something really critical
they bring to the table
the the sort of I mean you got to tell
the other side where you come from
otherwise you're making them guess and
you don't make good deals based on
guesswork
the analysts you got to think things
through you've got to come up with it
run some numbers you don't have to run
them all run any run some
any accommodator
like so many people look at the
accommodators and say that person's
making tons of deals what are they doing
it's in their demeanor it's in their
approach
um the just FYI for people that are
about to order this book you also kind
of give
how do you deal with the accommodator
how do you deal with these sort of songs
you give both sides of the spectrum uh
I'll fast forward a little bit we
mentioned this briefly this this
Ackerman bargain bargaining and this is
the I call the system the acronym
Ackerman model because it came from this
guy named Mike Ackerman an ex-cia guy
who founded a kidnap for ransom
consulting company based out of Miami on
many kidnappings we'd constantly be
paired with Ackerman guys
never Mike himself who helped design
this haggle and you lay out this haggle
it's a systemized and easy remember
process that has only four steps
well you go to six steps here
um number one set your Target price
which is your goal
then you set your first offer at 65 of
your Target price then you calculate
three raises of decreasing increments 85
95 and 100 percent
use lots of empathy and different ways
of saying no to get the other side to
counter before you increase your offer
when calculating the final final amount
use precise non-round numbers like 37
893 rather than thirty eight thousand
it gives the number credibility and
weight on your final number throw a
non-monetary item that you probably
don't want to show you're at your limit
so this is a pretty cool little system
yeah is that is that something you could
advise someone to use when they're going
to shop for a new car or a used car yeah
yeah it's not a bad model it it's if you
if you're gonna bargain
it's the most effective bargaining model
out there nothing beats it
uh getting into the slot it might be the
last chapter find the Black Swan and we
haven't mentioned this yet but you've
got the Black Swan group this is your
consulting firm
and
quick description of the Black Swan
Black Swan Theory tells us that things
happen that were previously thought to
be impossible or never thought of at all
this is not the same as saying that
sometimes things happen against a one in
a million odds but rather that things
never imagined do come to pass
the idea of the back Black Swan was
popularized by Nasim taleb and his
best-selling books Fooled by Randomness
and the Black Swan but the term goes
back much further until the 17th century
people could only imagine white swans
because all swans ever seen had
possessed white feathers in the 17th
century London it was common to refer to
impossible things as black swans but
when the but then the Dutch explorer
William Devlin sorry people of Holland
uh went to Western Australia in 1697 and
saw a Black Swan suddenly the
unthinkable and unthought was real
this is a crucial concept of negotiation
in every negotiation session there are
different kinds of information there are
those things we know like our
counterparts name and their offer and
our experiences from other negotiations
those are known knowns there are those
things we are certain that exist but we
don't know like possibility that the
other side might get sick and leave us
without another counterpart those are
known unknowns and they are like poker
wild cards you know they're out there
but you don't know who has them but most
important are those things we don't know
that we don't know
piece of information we've never
imagined that would be game changing if
uncovered maybe our counterpart wants
the deal to fail because he's leaving
for a competitor these unknown unknowns
are black swans
so this is obviously something highly
important to you since you named your
company the Black Swan
how did you stumble upon this idea well
they had their first
um talib's book in 2007 a Black Swan
got me thinking about it I like his
stuff I mean he's he's highly in-depth
thinker
um he's got a he's got a writing tone
that is not for everybody
but really in depth and and so I saw
that I I the idea and like the impact of
the Highland probable well that's what
we did all the time in negotiation It's
a combination of two things we're going
to change ourselves in subtle little
ways that the other side is never going
to see
and we're going to gain the upper hand
we're going to steer it we're going to
steer the negotiation and to the best
possible outcome now that that doesn't
mean that everything's going to a
positive outcome
but you've got to recognize what the
best possible outcome is so there's a
great metaphor for making tiny little
subtle changes in your negotiation
approach the other side is never going
to see
where you're going to make all the
difference it's completely invisible
and then while you're in the middle of
it
there's always stuff
great stuff will fall out of the sky if
you let it the other side's going to say
something that works for you they're
going to talk to you they're going to be
softer in a position than you realize
there's going to be pressures on them
that you don't understand something is
always always there and in many cases
the other side doesn't imagine it and to
draw a real fine point on this that a
lot of people Miss it's a reason why
reading body language to detect
deception
is almost a waste of time
because for you to deceive me you've got
to know it's important
to have a tell
you have to be consciously covering it
up
but a significant amount of that time
you don't even know it's important
so if I'm just looking for towels and
not getting you talking
the stuff that you didn't know was
important is never going to come out
so so what if so what if you're lying
number one
that doesn't tell me what the truth is
and if we're only focused on what you're
hiding rambling conversation what might
that look like
a woman who's getting
um funding for a film she's doing in Los
Angeles a couple years ago she's trying
to get 300 000 out of investor very
focused on this film being shot in LA
very focused on this amount of money
very focused on
what they're trying the point they're
trying to make in a film
but she's mirroring and labeling
and out of the blue it comes out that
the financier owns a castle in France
which would be a great setting for the
next film
something she never would have brought
up
the financier they're talking about a
film being shot in La martial arts this
and that all these other little things
you know female martial artists beating
up bad guys like how is she going to say
oh by the way you don't have I'm working
on another film we want to it's a
medieval film you don't happen to have a
castle in France do you like that is
never going to come up ever but she's
talking and she's labeling and marrying
and the next thing you know this this
thing comes out that the other person
has no idea makes any difference
changes the structuring of the whole
deal now instead of talking about one
film they're talking about multiple
films completely changes the complexion
of the the finances that are needed on
the first if she can go back out she's
already got partial packaging on a
second film like it changes everything
and there's no way that she would have
known to ask it and the person on the
other side was well instead of 300 Grand
what about my castle because that's not
going to do any good for a film in L.A
just little things like that well one
thing that
emphasized the importance of listening
is you know at one point you're talking
about a case you've got a guy that's you
know uh drives to drives to Washington
DC in a tractor he's going to blow
himself up he's going to blow up uh some
of the points yeah
and you know he's saying he's going to
blow himself up
um but when you actually have you're
having conversations with him and you've
got multiple people listening right
because listening is so important that
if you look if you can get more more
than one person you get two or three or
four people listening to the
conversation and they're gonna pick
things up that someone else might miss
and studying the transcript so you had
someone on the team that realized number
one he was a veteran how can we utilize
that and then someone realized he was
like of I don't want to say
fundamentalist Christian but a very
strong Christian and you had a certain
religious thing going on so are you able
to utilize these things that people
caught
just through listening and it changed
the Dynamics of the whole of the whole
negotiation right right kept him from
getting killed got him out of day early
and so that was you know short in a
timeline okay because he was he was
really at the end of his rope
and each hour went by he had less sleep
which increases the likelihood that he's
going to do something stupid we're still
not 100 sure that there are bombs there
and so if he'd made a particular move uh
towards where the possibility he had he
had his Jeep and a flatbed they said we
don't know their own explosives in a
Jeep and a flatbed if he goes there we
got to take him out
and we're talking to him and this comes
up and he's agreed to come out 72 hours
we want to cut try to cut 24 off of it
and when one of the female negotiators
Winnie Miller says you know
tell him tomorrow's the donor the third
day
which is 48 hours
and
I'll come out
it's what he says
and he had talked so much about the
military and his 82nd Airborne
experience
somebody else listening heard the
underlying strong Christian beliefs in
that his religion if you will
everybody's got a religion everybody
everybody
has got a religion just depend upon what
it is and how broadly you define it
uh just gonna hit some of these last
section of the book I'll cover
um but I just want to hit some of these
highlights here
let what you know your no knowns guide
you but not blind you
every case is new so remain flexible and
adaptable
black swans are leverage multipliers
remember the three types of Leverage and
you go over these in the book positive
which is the ability to give someone
what they want negative the ability to
hurt someone and normative using your
counterparts Norms to bring them around
again there's more detail on the book
inside the book work to understand the
other side's religion which you just
mentioned everybody's got a religion
digging into World Views inherently
implies moving beyond negotiation table
and into life emotional and otherwise of
your counterpart that's where black
black swans live
review everything you hear from your
counterpart you will not hear everything
the first time so double check compare
notes with team members use backup
listeners
exploit the similarity principle people
are more apt to concede to someone when
they share a culture someone they share
a cultural similarity with so dig for
what makes them tick and show that you
share common ground
when someone seems irrational or crazy
they most likely aren't faced with a
situation search for constraints hidden
desires and bad information
and last get FaceTime with your
counterpart 10 minutes of Face Time
often reveals more than days of research
pay special attention to your
counterparts verbal and non-verbal
communication at unguarded moments at
the beginning and the end of the session
or when someone says something out of
line
so
really uh really just
awesome points that apply to me they
apply to business they apply to
interacting with any human obviously
they apply to negotiations but
um there you go I mean we hit the the
wave tops of some of the last I mean
probably read less than five percent of
this book uh so many
good stories and again I I felt I feel
kind of bad that I skipped a lot of the
a lot of the stories themselves uh but
get the book
and and that way you can hear some of
the examples behind this so
what so what so what are you up to right
now what do we got we got the Black Swan
group right
yeah we're coaching and training
negotiations of all the companies out
there you can get training from very few
and we'll coach you which sort of shocks
me
like how do you how do you how do you
not believe in your stuff enough where
you you'll coach I mean literally the
real definition of a coach is somebody
you go into the game
but the coach is right there
prepping you you come out of the game
you could talk like how do you teach
this stuff
and not be willing to coach it
and so we we coach across the board it's
a much bigger aspect of the business
than I ever thought it would be
we gotta just finish the documentary
film called tactical empathy
um looking
premiered in Beverly Hills about 10 days
ago
taking our time on a distribution deal
we'll see what happens with that
outlining a lot of stuff that we're
talking about is it full length
documentary 54 minutes 54 minute
documentary
got a book uh for real estate agents the
full fee agent coming out
um
Steve Shull the guy that did the book
with me
interesting cat
I know Steve for well over a year before
I find out he played in the NFL
like most NFL guys you know
the first five minutes
not only that
Steve was a Super Bowl Captain dang
he didn't just play in the NFL he didn't
just play on a team that went to the
Super Bowl he was a captain of the team
like I think I finally found that out
after I knew him like four years like he
just he doesn't lead with that stuff
but understands the value of coaching
because
he played for Don Shula
he played for some real coaches
so he shares a coaching philosophy that
you know the stuff that we coach you on
if you do what we ask you to do it's
going to work
so the full free agent's coming out in
about two months and then uh my son
Brandon and I and another colleague are
working on a follow-up that never split
the difference should be on about a year
nice uh yeah the coaching piece
I always tell people with uh with
leadership it's not an inoculation you
don't just get like a shot and now
you're good now you get it you don't go
to the gym one time and now you're in
shape you don't pick up a Guitar get
taught and now you know how to play it
it's the same thing when they go you're
not going to say oh I read the book and
now I'm good to go no you actually need
to train it you need to get coached on
it that's why that's why you got to do
that follow-up so that's awesome we do
the same thing at our company I mean
most of the companies that we work with
we do long-term engagements with them uh
Black Swan
ltd.com that's where that's where people
if they want coaching if they want to
get uh
deeper on this stuff you're also on
social media you got on Facebook and
Instagram you're at Black Swan LTD
you're on Twitter at Black Swan grp
you personally aren't on Instagram
big social media guy over here oh yeah
at the FBI negotiator so did I get all
those things right is there anything
else we need to know about yeah I know
those those are good on the website
blackswonltd.com we got a lot of free
stuff
there's to get your skill level up like
wherever you are we can meet you where
you are the another thing we put out
that that is free
but that's not what makes it valuable we
gotta we got a Weekly Newsletter
concise actionable
not 10 articles where you're trying to
decide what to do next
like one article roughly 700 words
complete actionable concise stuff the
newsletter's free you sign up for it on
the website you get it emailed to you on
Tuesday Mornings wherever you in the
world you are
take the free stuff
you can get a long way with the book and
free stuff alone yeah and everybody
that's listening just beat the king of
negotiation because you're getting the
stuff for free so just get in there and
get it take it from them otherwise you
don't win right you want to get one up
on the FBI negotiator you got to go hey
yeah I got this from the I got this from
the master of negotiation I got it for
free that's how good you are so get in
there and sign up for that uh that scene
that's that gets us up to present day
yeah pretty much um the master classes
out there you know you and I were
talking earlier about the master class
is good it's also it's insane
how cheap that is as far as costs like
the master class might be the best deal
on Earth
and my negotiation course and a whole
bunch of other cool stuffs on there
iger's got a course
and sorkin's got a course like if
whatever you want to learn you're going
to find it on Master Class
so you're on there as well awesome all
right
well now you know what time it is Echo
Charles yes do you have any questions
yes oh here we go well I took the Master
Class by the way very helpful very good
that's a very well done one
um what's your thoughts on like good the
whole good cop bad cop uh interrogation
anything that's a manipulation or where
you're not being genuine and honest and
if you're a good cop bad cop you're
probably one of you is play acting yeah
yeah and it's as a long-term strategy
like you might get short-term what you
need but you're always going to find
always going to find that you need
long-term cooperation and to engage in
something that's guaranteed to cause it
to go bad
it's not just from from a mercenary
standpoint you don't do stuff you know
it's gonna
hurt you in the long run
so back to the accommodator so if I'm
running late not that I ever run late
but hypothetically if I'm running late
and then Jocko texts me how long
is it going to be till you get here and
I know probably it's going to be like 20
minutes probably but I say in my head
if there's no traffic light stopping me
if traffic is good I could probably be
there in six so I tell them about five
minutes
because I want to avoid giving him the
bad news up front you see I'm saying and
then I'm hopeful that I make it in the
five is that me being the accommodator
yeah I think so and I think that's
probably one of the biggest mistakes
people make on a regular basis
constantly like and and the fix is the
opposite
like if you if you know you're 20
minutes away tell them 25. yeah here's
my thinking if I would ever that ever
were ever to happen
I'm thinking I give them the good news
so he's not that mad at me it's insane
so if I give him the worst possible news
for that 10 minutes or whatever he's
gonna be mad see I'm saying then he's
already mad when I walk in there but if
the small chance arises that I get there
in the five minutes boom easy money
yeah that's how it plays out in your
head
and that that is so common like and my
girlfriend is an accommodator a
wonderful human being brilliant
entrepreneur like so many things about
her that are just brilliant she's and
she's also she's gorgeous
I'm talking to her on the phone the
other day she's saying you know she's
nice enough she's in the middle of Zoom
calls she takes a call anyway she says
hey
says I'm in the middle of a business
call I'll call you back in 15 minutes
I go okay
and then that night I called her I said
that was the longest 15 minutes I've
ever heard yeah like I didn't I I knew
when somebody gives me a vague amount of
time and it's not just her anybody
I go on about my day because you're
trying to be nice you know you're trying
really hard to keep the other person
from being in a bad place you
and Time After Time After Time After
Time
the lights are not all in line
and the data that you get overwhelmingly
says that's going to go bad and they're
almost everybody still does it that was
one of my favorite stories from
mcraven's Book C stories and you might
have been one of those guys out there
they're running some up in the Caribbean
and a helicopters are late picking them
up and they are not uh outfitted for the
water temperature water's warm but it
still ain't 98.6 and the Choppers one of
the Choppers going to show
and that Choppers uh 15 minutes
and they were there for three hours
they would you know and that's that's
that's not a military op that's human
beings trying to be nice to other human
beings
and I you know it just doesn't work out
so the flip side is
overestimate the time
you tell them 25 minutes you're here in
20. he's delighted with you he thinks
you're great delighted might be a strong
but I'll tell you you know someone else
the airlines do this yeah oh yeah like
there's the last time no but the
opposite now they caught on because
their biggest criticism was whether or
not their planes are late so it doesn't
matter what airline it is
I fly all the time plane lands and they
go like well our Gate's not open yet so
we got to wait another 20 minutes before
we get at the gate in the first couple
times that happened I remember and I
said out loud in the airport was it a
surprise that we showed up
like this plane is really big I know
they picked it up on radar they saw us
coming from a long way away how is the
gate still occupied we're not here as a
surprise
the airline knew all along when they
were going to get there but to fool you
they told you they were going to be
there at three o'clock you made your
plans around three o'clock they land at
2 30 which is a half an hour early you
think the airline's great you're mad at
the airport
nobody ever blames it the airline knew
all along when they were really gonna
get it so when you show up early when
you overestimate at the time the people
you're doing business with love you they
think you're fantastic you put time back
in their day
yeah this thing goes deep man yeah well
plus just like uh building a
relationship with people the more you
tell them things that's really going to
happen you know the the higher the trust
level goes yeah as opposed to telling
someone you're gonna be there in six
minutes and you show up in 16 minutes
what about uh if someone has food in
their teeth and you don't want to tell
them a combinator right
yeah that's gonna go bad you gotta know
right just gotta tell them right it
helps them out big picture but you don't
want to deliver that bad news is kind of
the deal what's the plight right of the
accommodator just hopeful like Fallout
and no one has to say if you're over
there trying to figure out if you're an
accommodator or not I'm gonna go ahead
and say let's I'll solve that riddle for
you right now you're in a god of it
accommodator for sure hey we're all
doing the best we can right on right on
anything else Echo Charles that is it is
honor I've I've followed you I actually
I got that book right when it came out
so thank you that's completely
appreciate it what year did the book
come out 2016. they haven't been out for
a while awesome uh Chris any thought any
closing thoughts from you
no I've been I've enjoyed the
conversation
um
delighted at how thoroughly you
understand how this applies the
leadership and everything else I mean
you're seeing a parallels right away
you know I've listened to your other
podcasts we talk about like you know I
left High School Not educated dude
but you're a learner
which is really cool which is really
cool well thank you appreciate it and uh
thanks for coming on thanks for coming
down here and thanks for sharing your
experiences and and all these Lessons
Learned with everybody I mean it's just
awesome that people can pick up this
book and learn what you've learned over
the Decades of work you put into this
and of course more important uh thanks
for your service thanks for your service
and in law enforcement in the FBI Thanks
For Fighting terrorists and kidnappers
and and drug dealers and criminals to
keep us safe here on the home front
um and the same to you brother yeah it
was an honor to be able to serve yeah
amen exactly it was a privilege all
right thank you
and with that Chris Voss has left the
building
Echo Charles yes sir
excited about that one huh yes you like
that one I liked it though a lot to
learn yeah what was your uh
big takeaway besides the fact that
you're an accommodator I know I felt it
right when he was explaining it I was
like bro that's well he also said they
make the most deals well there you go
right establishing Rapport all that oh
and I ain't look am I am am I an
accommodator I don't know but if I'm not
I know I have accommodator traits from
time to time we know that you're not
analytic
okay I already know that you're not
assertive there's only three options
yeah okay well no no no we go for a
blend right yeah you blend blend but
your high percentage accommodator maybe
all right we'll go with that from now on
I'm gonna keep an eye on it because I I
like to know what I don't know
so he seems saying so it did shed some
like that's a good idea on that thing
um but the interesting takeaway
geography is more influential than
ethnicity in building and it makes sense
because in Hawaii everybody's mixed and
you know there's all different kind of
community but if you're from
and I'm from Waimanalo yeah we're good
we can be in Dubai me new brothers 100
so boom
um so that made a lot of sense to me and
what did what did shed some light on is
some of your tactics as well oh in a
good ways band so
um
okay one time you called me out for
clicking the pen all right I edit it out
so it's not on any episode but it's one
and the way you said it was
is that clicking going to show up on the
recording do you think you said you
think like me it was like my idea kind
of a thing you know like I have to
figure out for myself if it's gonna as
opposed to hey that clicking is annoying
and it's gonna ruin the take or whatever
you know
I was like oh I see because it was
effective and if you look back on the
video I think I uh published that
outtake somewhere okay
um if you look on the video I responded
like totally like it worked that little
tactic
no the uh it really was cool to read the
book and to identify all these things
that their psychological
their psychological traits or
psychological characteristics or
psychological Maneuvers yeah so they
work again they work with human beings
so it doesn't matter your leadership
your interrogation your your negotiation
they're all they're all going to have
some similar
similar approaches yeah and they are and
so yeah it was really cool really cool
to read about really cool to to go
through and then be able to sit here
with Chris and talk through it uh and
you know it's awesome he and again I
kind of did go through I talked about it
on the podcast but like the book has a
bunch of cool stories in it right
and is there a temptation just to jump
into like negotiation hostage
negotiation all that stuff but
I I felt like I really kind of wanted to
dive into the tactics the principles
themselves so maybe I was a little bit
selfish on that one but
yeah you know what I realized uh about
you or somebody told you this before
where
your your interest is like it's like a
80 20 where you like how things work for
sure but only like 20 80 is you're
interested in okay so what do we do
about it so like and I think I'm kind of
the if I'm like really trying to be
introspective I'm kind of the opposite
so I'm like a 2080 kind of a scenario so
anytime I start going deep on how things
work I see your eyes kind of glaze over
and then you snapped in you'd be like
okay this is well this is what you do
this is what you do it's like you uh you
interrupt it with the next step kind of
a thing so it so I can see why you'd be
really into the the stories but yeah I
think the tactics are are the ones that
a lot of the time anyway if you listen
to them it's like okay now I can use
them in my particular life I think
they're both together or the most
effective for sure yeah the other thing
that I I thought about look I don't care
how long a podcast is gonna be I don't
care for 12 hours but I also
you know you have to think all right if
we start getting into all these cool
stories he's gotten here they all have
their own
branches and you know sub stories and
details that's gonna be you know we get
to a point where diminishing returns
right we just have a 19-hour podcast in
which point just get on Just just go and
read the book yourself or go get the
audiobook and go with it that way so
that's kind of the kind of how I went
with it but uh just just awesome to have
them on here and and learn from
you know the subtitle the book is
negotiating as if your life depends on
it depended on it right so he has
countless times negotiated stuff that it
where someone's life or lives were on
the line literally
doesn't get more you know I I used to
say about extreme ownership combat is
like life but Amplified and intensified
yeah
well
if you can negotiate for someone's life
you can negotiate for the car that you
want the used car that you want to pay
you know 2 700 bucks for instead of the
4 200 bucks that they're offering it yep
so all right there you go uh thanks for
joining us everybody if you wanna if you
like this podcast if you want to support
it
and you want to actually support
yourself cognitively you want to be
cognitively ready for those moments
that's why I'm three deep
right now with Jocko fuel I think with
discipline goes now normally you'd be
thinking oh you drank three energy
drinks today yeah you've had a bad day
you have trouble you have to mark this
down as a negative on your overall
health we're actually not doing that at
all not even doing that at all
because I had one what times it's four
o'clock right now I had the first one at
like 10 30. prior to a Echelon front
Academy call
then I had another one as we kind of
started this thing and then I had
another one as we kind of got halfway
through this thing so what does that
mean I've had does that mean I've had a
bunch of sugar doesn't mean I've had 82
grams no I've had zero sugar that's a
monk fruit which is a beautiful thing
I've had have I had what would that be
three times have I had 600 milligrams of
caffeine no I haven't even had 300
milligrams caffeine
so if you want to be good too but you
want that energy yeah go to
jockofuel.com get yourself some Mulk
which is dessert
get yourself some go you can also go to
Wawa
we got the ready to drink protein
available available in Wawa
you can you Jocko fuel.com you can check
it
um we're getting there but the ready to
drink stuff is kind of a game changer
yeah it's good
I told you about the chocolate milk
versus milk right yes sir with my
daughter yeah who is not gonna pull any
punches yeah
she she looked Pete we know we sat down
a table at camp and Pete was all like
bro it's better than chocolate milk and
she looked at him like he was just a
liar you know what I mean I almost had
to like get her to settle down you know
like you can't look at a you know a
grown man like he's a liar but she kind
of looked at him like yeah right well
the good thing is Pete was like oh let's
go yeah let's go get him out so he got
out the straight regular like chocolate
milk yeah and Mork side by side taste
this well blind taste test she she was
like dang that's the that's the true
that's probably the truest
and most awesome test that's ever been
performed for taste in the world dip in
the world probably right so there you go
get yourself some mulch get yourself
some ready to drink milk vitamin shops
got this stuff as well go in there
thing is hey gotta remember about Wawa
somebody somebody hit me up on social
media they cleared the shelves in Wawa
thank you
because look it's a war out there
have I explained the war to you a little
bit yeah it's a war the big companies
don't like the little companies yeah the
big companies have
overwhelming Firepower and the term in
in the form of cash money that they can
throw to try and Crush
the the up and comers they don't want
that competition they want to smash they
want to smash Jocko fuel they want to
smash discipline go yeah
so what they do is they make Maneuvers
they throw money at at stores
and the stores like to offer something
else but they got to be able to got to
make sense so when you go and you clear
the shelves at Wawa thank you when you
go any of these any of these stores when
you go in there and get after it it
shows them that there's demand signal to
retail and they want to keep us
as opposed to when somebody throws a
bunch of money at them say we want you
to we want you to get rid of those guys
yeah
think about that that's called a
monopoly yeah right yeah it's a monopoly
those are Monopoly moves
and so we appreciate it when you help us
fight the man
right the corporate
entity that's not a person there's no
person those other companies not people
you know they're not people
they're just big corporate entities
there's big giant corporate entities
yeah no people there no humans
yes we're human we're here we're getting
after it so anyways appreciate it
jockoffuel.com go get some of that
originusa.com
get yourself some American made
everything
hunt gear we're getting it out
certain pieces are out
the pants are out
the some of the shirts are out
just get on there and order it if if
it's not available right now we're
making it and if you want to get it you
got to order it now I'm sorry but you
got to order it now and then we'll get
it to you as soon as it's ready as soon
as it's been made here in America by
American hands jeans boots
so that's what we're doing originusa.com
get yourself some of that support
America
and support yourself it's true also
chocolate store chocolate store called
Jaco store this one equals Freedom
Shirts new one is out it's been out
it's a good one Whatever standard issue
one standard issue multiple forms
multiple forms uh get one look is
Christmas near
it's Christmas near technically maybe
maybe not but bro they already have
Christmas stuff available where was it
my wife came home and said they like she
went to Target or Walmart or something
and they were like she's like Christmas
gear is up you know available so is it
near
this is something to think about we'll
say that so yes we've got some good
stuff on there some kid stuff on there
Warrior kids stuff on there as well so
we kind of got everything something for
everybody if you want to check out let's
face it the warrior kids need that
Christmas hitter it yeah that'll be a
good clothing gift I've got some
accessories we've got some good stuff on
there also
we got the shirt Locker
the Halloween one is with Halloween
no another good gift idea by the way got
some gift cards too on there the gift
that keeps on giving that keeps 100
every month get somebody the shirt
Locker and then they get a new t-shirt
every month you know that has layers in
it layers could be one layer could be
seven layers you get seven layers do we
charge by the layer no no the layers are
just part of the pack included you're
right but yes cool designs people like
really like the designs this is what I'm
finding out and thank you thanks thanks
for everyone for the feedback so yeah
really good SRI Locker man stuff women's
stuff hoodies hats all that cool
stuff.com stuff across the board
subscribe to the podcast you know that
drunderground.com
we've been recording those yeah putting
word out answering your questions
uh if you go to Jocko underground.com
look people are getting censored right
now people are getting banned whatever
we're not gonna that's not gonna happen
to us at least on the platform that we
could happen on this platform whatever
form you're listening to they could ban
us yeah
if that happens we'll be on Jocko
underground.com it costs eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month if you can't
afford it
no big deal we still we're still here to
support look we know hard times right
now right if you can't afford it email
assistance Jocko underground.com if you
can't afford it cool support the cause
capital t h e the capital c a u s e the
cause
freedom
psychological warfare we got
flipsidecanvas.com books obviously never
split the difference
by Chris Voss check that book out and
then all the books I've written good get
that book only cry for the living by
Holly McKay
uh just a great book we put it out on
Jocko publishing check that one out and
then all the books I've written you know
what they are
so go get them get the warrior kid books
let's face it that book would have
helped you set out so much if you had it
when you were a kid it would help me and
if you know kids any kids get them that
book once again Christmas cool
get it make it happen uh Echelon front
you heard me talking a lot about
leadership today well we solve problems
through leadership at Echelon front go
to echelonfront.com and also up and
coming we've got an uh a little
something that we call
the Roll Call
which roll call is an event
and we've got one October 17th in St
Louis Missouri
how to just check this because they told
me they still got some seats our stuff
sells out quick so roll call is for
police law enforcement
First Responders
military
October 17th St Louis Missouri if you
can if you're in that category go and
check that out it's going to be it's
it's our leadership principles kind of
geared toward that group of people
also we have online training
said this today you're not going to get
good at leadership
with one book or with one rehearsal or
one practice no you need to get in there
go to extreme ownership.com learn about
life
Square your life away
extreme ownership.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
also check out Micah Fink he's got his
program taking you up and taking vets up
in the wilderness
so they can find themselves again and
rebuild Heroes and horses.org
if you want to follow Chris
Voss and the blocks Black Swan group
it's it's black swanltd.com
Facebook and Instagram is Black Swan LTD
Twitter at Black Swan group and Chris is
on Instagram
he's at the FBI negotiator and of course
we are also on social media and whatnot
Twitter Graham Facebook Echoes at Echo
Charles I'm at Jocko willink of course
watch out because that algorithm's
sitting there waiting to grab you by the
throat and drag you into Oblivion don't
let it uh thanks once again to Chris
Voss for joining us for teaching us
about negotiation and thanks to Chris
for his service in the police department
and the FBI
thanks to all the FBI agents that are
out there right now
doing their best to keep us safe
and the same goes to the rest of our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders thanks for
everything that you all do to keep us
safe and of course thanks to our
military men and women who are on the
front lines around the world right now
we live in Freedom because of the
sacrifices you make
thank you for your service and everyone
else out there life is a negotiation
and people are not rational
they are filled with emotions and biases
and judgments and that includes you
so pay attention
and listen more than you talk not just
in negotiation
but in leadership and life
and until next time this is zeko and
Jocko
out